Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Elon Musk will jetzt eine eigene Partei gründen.
Endlich Spaltung bei der amerikanischen Volksfront.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 528 vom 6.
Juli 2025, es heißt draußen, Linus schwitzt und ja.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt, ich habe nur gesagt, es ist warm.
Ja gut, schwitzer. Naja, ist ja klar, wie die Partei dann heißt, ne?
Amerika.
Hat er gesagt, ne?
Volksfront von Amerika oder amerikanische Volksfront.
Ich glaube, das benennt er nach oben. Die heißt dann einfach X-Partei.
Ah!
Der nennt doch alles X. X-Party oder so. Oder auf X-Videos kann er dann seine,
Werbespots veröffentlichen.
Dieser Typ.
Also, ich meine, es wird natürlich irgendwie scheitern, aber wie du schon richtig angemerkt hast,
also alles, was für potenzielle Verwirrung bei den Wählern im rechten Spektrum
sorgt, das kann nur gut sein, aber ehrlich gesagt würde ich mir da nicht so viel Hoffnung machen.
Also, Zweifelsfall, weißt du ja, wie es ist bei den Rechten.
Die versammeln sich dann halt einfach hinter dem Führer du jour und da wird
dann nicht aufgespalten.
Das machen nur die Linken. Ja, die Linken, da sagt dann einer ein falsches Wort.
Ja, gleichzeitig, es reichen halt wenige, wenige hunderttausend Wählerinnen,
um die Republikaner die Mehrheit zu kosten.
Falls die Wahlgesetze noch angewendet werden.
Falls die Partei überhaupt zugelassen wird von Donald Trump.
Ja, oder falls auch noch gewählt wird. Da bin ich mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher.
Naja, aber die Hoffnung stirbt ja wie immer zuletzt und so auch hier.
Ja. So ist das mit Hoffnung und Optimismus.
Es wird ja für alles gescholten. Wenn ich optimistisch bin, Stichwort goldene
20er, dann kriege ich das jetzt jahrelang aufs Brot geschmiert.
Du hast gesagt, alles wird gut und es ist nicht so gut, wie ich will. Also bist du schuld.
Super.
Wenn man aber jetzt der totale Doomsayer ist,
Weiß ich nicht, dafür wird man dann nicht gescholten. Also man kann die ganze
Zeit sagen, ja, die Welt ist schlecht, das Ende ist nah,
und dann kommt das Ende aber nicht und man darf dann immer weiter noch unbehelligt
rumlaufen und nichts ist.
Aber so für Optimismus und Hoffnung, dafür wird man bestauchen.
Das ist out. Optimismus und Hoffnung ist out.
Das geht gar nicht, ja. Weil die Leute wollen gar nicht.
Die wollen es zwar, aber sie wollen es wahrscheinlich nicht hören und wenn es
dann einer ausspricht und es passiert dann nicht, dann ist der dann halt schuld. Ganz einfach.
Ich hatte das ja in der letzten Folge angekündigt bei der Fusion,
gab es ja diese schönen Tag,
Vorträge und Sessions, die ich da mal organisieren durfte und da war die meisten,
waren zumindest, also waren zumindest ermutigend.
Also eigentlich alle, sonst hätte ich die Leute ja nicht geholt,
wenn ich da inspirierende Personen da ausgewählt habe.
Dann hatte ich ja in der letzten Sendung schon die Themen gesagt.
Wir hatten den Arne Semsrott da mit Zukunft mit oder ohne Nazis.
Dann Hanna Voss und Vivien Kube, das sind Anwältinnen und die sind...
Gibt es da Aufzeichnungen von oder nicht? Sonst brauchst du das gar nicht runterbieten.
Jetzt wollte ich zumindest mal sagen, wer da war.
Achso, ja.
Steini war der Letzte, deswegen war Anke Domstadt-Berg da, Julian Hessenthaler,
Katharina Nocun, Lotte Lallois, Pia Klemp und dann Steini.
Auf Steini wollte ich zu sprechen kommen, der sich in seinem Vortrag bemüht
hat, weiter zu betonen, dass sich doch viele Dinge in die richtige Richtung entwickeln.
Beispielsweise bei der Solarenergie.
Und dass es da doch einiges gibt, über das man sich freuen kann.
Das fand ich sehr angenehm.
Dass es auch positive Dinge gibt.
Ich glaube, Optimismus ist einfach nicht en vogue. Also es ist einfach nicht gefragt.
Das hat aber, das hat auch sehr fürchterliche Konsequenzen für vieles weitere.
Also ich meine, natürlich sieht es gerade nicht enorm gut aus,
aber das heißt nun mal nicht, dass man sich irgendwie gegenseitig jetzt anpaulen
muss, weil alles schlecht ist oder alles schlecht wird oder so.
Kannst du mir nochmal kurz das Ja sagen, an dem alles gut aussah?
Ähm Also Ich würde Ich müsste den doch immer schwarz,
Standard Vielleicht mal kurz so Love Parade,
irgendwie alle auf Drogen Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen Und dann so dieser gloriose
2000 Moment und diese Illusion Von ewigen Frieden Die da aufgerufen wurde Da
würde ich dann sagen wir mal so für Berlin Oder Deutschland,
Würde ich nochmal so eine kurze Ausnahme machen Aber generell wird ja immer
der Niedergang von allem Möglichen beklagt.
Ja, bisher in der Regel nicht des Planeten, aber auch das.
Waldsterben, Ozonloch, das waren alle schon so Dinge, wo der Weltuntergang nah war.
Ich meine, die Wachtturm-Verkäufer, die laufen ja schon seit Jahrzehnten die
ganze Zeit mit, das Ende ist nah durch die Giebungen.
Ja, bei denen fehlt natürlich so ein bisschen die gewissenschaftliche Basis.
Das hat ja nun die Leute nicht gerade gestört, schlechte Laune zu bekommen.
Das ist ja nun sehr verbreitet. Das ist ja quasi the original Schwurbler.
Also ich verstehe das ja alles und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass es jetzt keine
bedrohlichen Bewegungen gäbe.
Aber wir konzentrieren uns zu sehr auf das und wir schauen zu wenig auf das,
was auch sich entwickelt und damit will ich jetzt auch nicht gleich wieder in
so ein alles wird gut Ding weil es wird immer,
immer alles gleichzeitig sein Dinge werden schlechter werden andere Dinge werden besser werden,
zwangsläufig Welche.
Waren das jetzt nochmal?
Ja das mit der Energiewende zum Beispiel ist so ein Ding.
Ich meine, ich will jetzt hier keinen Energie-Podcast aufmachen,
aber die Tatsache ist, dass die Technologie, die wir benötigen,
um das alles umzudrehen, die existiert bereits.
Und zwar in mannigfaltiger Form.
Und es ist jetzt sozusagen nur noch das Problem mit der Politik,
die halt nicht, also wir haben ja hier diese,
Wisst ihr ja, was wir jetzt gerade haben? Auch hier in Berlin.
Der Style der Zeit ist, der konservative Style ist, alles muss jetzt erstmal zurückgedreht werden.
Also, weil es droht Zukunft.
Und wenn Zukunft droht, dann müssen die Konservativen unbedingt was dagegen unternehmen.
So lange, bis es sich nicht mehr verhindern lässt.
Bis es einfach Gegenwart ist.
Ja, also umweltgerechter und menschenfreundlicher Umbau einer Stadt,
ja habt ihr sie denn noch alle, da müssen wir alles dagegen tun.
Es wird sich nicht verhindern lassen und natürlich verzögern sie es einfach
maximal, aber es wird halt einfach kommen, weil es einfach das ist,
was alle wollen und weil es sich technisch machen lässt.
Oder diese ganze Debatte über, ja, vielleicht hätten wir ja doch ein Atomkraftwerk
und lass doch nochmal Atomkraft.
Die rennen ja auch gegen die Wand, wenn die bei diesen Energieunternehmen aufkreuzen
und sagen so, ja, wie wär's denn nochmal mit Atomkraft, das war doch so geil
damals. Dann sagen die so, habt ihr einen Taschenrechner?
Lest ihr Zeitungen? Habt ihr mal geguckt, was es kostet, Strom zu erzeugen mit Solarpanels?
Kein Mensch würde jetzt noch auf die Idee kommen, Atomkraftwerke zu bauen mit
dem Risiko, mit den Kosten, mit den Laufzeiten, wie lange das dauert,
bis du sowas überhaupt genehmigt bekommst und gebaut bekommst und betrieben bekommst und so weiter.
Das ganze Risiko und auch die anderen Ressourcen, die du auch für diese ganzen
blöden Technologien brauchst, wie zum Beispiel Atomkraftwerke,
sehen wir jetzt in Frankreich,
die fahren dann jeden Sommer ihre Atomkraftwerke runter. Warum?
Weil sie kein Wasser haben.
Ja?
Die einzigen Energiegewinnungssysteme, die kein Wasser brauchen, Solar und Wind.
Und von daher ergibt sich das einfach automatisch und sogar in Deutschland ist
im Sommer der Großteil des Stroms, wird schon entsprechend generiert von umweltschonenden Systemen.
Das Problem ist die mangelnde Elektrifizierung.
Das ist das Ding. Also wir können mit Elektrizität dieses ganze Energiethema lösen.
Das ist vollkommen klar. Die Technologie existiert.
Aber solange wir halt irgendwie dann doch nochmal Gasheizung fördern und all
diesen Quatsch. Dann nicht.
Dann wird das halt nichts. Aber wir sind jetzt an so einem Punkt angelangt,
man kann alles elektrisch machen.
Fahren, heizen, kühlen, Internet, nicht, alles funktioniert elektrisch und es
muss jetzt auch alles elektrisch werden und dann geht es auch voran.
Das wird auch passieren.
Kriegen wir die Kurve nochmal?
Naja, aber es geht um Optimismus. Wir werden jetzt gleich auch nochmal das Feedback
zur letzten Sendung aufgreifen und auch da steckt dieselbe Frage nach wie schauen
wir auf die Welt auch tief mit drin.
Ich würde da vielleicht noch so kurz einen kleinen Tauner, eine kleine Anmerkung,
über die ich sehr viel nachdenke in letzter Zeit,
aus vielen unterschiedlichen Gründen.
Man kann sich ja so ein bisschen, also je nachdem wie viel Freizeit man hat
oder so, kann man ja steuern, worauf man seine Aufmerksamkeit konzentriert.
Und es wird ja Leute nicht überraschen, dass das Gehirn sich mit dem beschäftigt,
wohin man seine Aufmerksamkeit denkt.
Und ich stelle,
manchmal fest, dass Menschen und ich will auch gar nicht sagen,
dass man jetzt frei über seine Aufmerksamkeit herrscht es gibt ja auch bestimmte
Probleme, die beschäftigen einen dann ewig und dann man gräbt sich da vielleicht
auch rein und frisst sich in so ein Thema fest aber so ganz grundsätzlich,
hilft das ein bisschen im Auge zu halten,
oder vielleicht ein bisschen zu reflektieren,
was wo man seine Aufmerksamkeit und seinen Augenmerk hinrichtet.
Und zum Beispiel mal ein bisschen zu reflektieren, ob man sich zum Beispiel
die ganze Zeit über Probleme Gedanken macht, die außerhalb der eigenen Einflussmöglichkeiten sind.
Das ist halt sehr schlecht, weil da kannst du ja nichts dran ändern.
Das wird auf jeden Fall immer schlechter.
Und du hast jeden Anlass, davon auszugehen, dass es immer schlimmer wird.
Und gleichzeitig kann man natürlich auch seine Aufmerksamkeit mit Themen beschäftigen,
die einen in irgendeiner Weise freuen, wo es irgendeine positive Entwicklung
gibt, sei es irgendetwas.
Aber ich glaube, dass das durchaus eine...
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass einige Leute das nicht so machen oder vielleicht
unbewusst nicht machen oder es vielleicht besser mal bewusst tun sollten,
dass sie sich überlegen, wie kann ich mich selber und meine Empfindungen aus
so einem negativen Gedankenstrudel vielleicht langsam wieder rausbewegen.
Ohne Drogen. Das wäre verrückt. Ja, jetzt wird es völlig verrückt.
Da merke ich, dass das, ich merke immer Leute, wo ich denke,
boah Junge, such dir mal was Schönes,
schaff dir etwas Nettes, du hast ja Möglichkeiten,
auch so angenehme Erfolgserlebnisse im Kleinen, was auch immer das ist,
ich will da ja gar keine Vorgaben machen, aber.
Ja, aber du hast recht und es ist ja, also generell finde ich,
es ist nicht nur jetzt mental gesünder,
sondern auch hilfreicher in der politischen Agitation, insbesondere in so einem
eher linken Umfeld, sagen wir mal, ja,
sich nicht die ganze Zeit mit so Doomsday-Parolen zu garnieren.
Weil dieses permanente, die Welt geht unter Geschreie,
ist halt nicht sexy. Ja, es verfängt halt auch einfach nicht.
Leute wollen dann auch am Ende einfach mal einen Wick gewiesen bekommen und
da ist halt irgendwie, alles ist schlecht, sowieso, ja, okay,
gut, dann kann ich auch gleich zur AfD gehen, das sagen die ja auch.
Das ist sozusagen eigentlich deren Methode.
Und ich glaube auch, also ich kann das jetzt nicht so klar postulieren,
Aber ich sehe da schon Zusammenhänge zwischen diesem irgendwie alles ist scheiße
und jetzt will ich das alles brennen sehen und auch einer Lethargie und negativer Gefühlshaltung,
so eine Mischung, so eine Ecke und dann diese aktiv positiver Vibe in irgendeiner
Weise noch kämpferisch und Freude.
Das ist immer in meiner Wahrnehmung das absolut Entscheidende,
wenn wir das Lachen verloren haben, wenn das Lachen vergangen ist,
dann haben wir wirklich verloren.
Und solange wir noch die freundlicheren, lustigeren und spielerischeren sind,
glaube ich auch, da bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass da auf jeden Fall immer vorne ist.
Bei dem Positiven.
Schöne Kurve genommen.
Ja, einfach mal Meta.
Kommen wir zum Feedback.
Gab es welches?
Wir haben sehr viel Feedback bekommen, weil wir ja in der letzten Sendung ein
bisschen über KI gesprochen haben und zu vielen unterschiedlichen Aspekten dieses
Gesprächs haben wir Feedback bekommen.
Einiges davon wollen wir wie immer behandeln und ich glaube,
das Erste, was wir uns rausgesucht haben, war KI und Programmieren.
Das ist ja Tims Welt.
Ich schreibe ja meine Python-Skripte immer noch selber mit Stack Overflow.
Du ewig gestriger, du.
Ja, ne? Früher hat man sich auch immer alles abgeguckt.
Da haben wir alles selber gemacht.
Ja, also es gab eine ganze Menge Kommentare. Da war so alles mit drin,
so Angst, Ablehnung, Durch wahrgenommene Fehlfunktionen, aber auch Überschätzung
und Drohung vor Abhängigkeiten.
Da haben wir ein paar rausgegriffen. Alles können wir ja nicht wiedergeben. Es war wirklich viel.
Danke auch dafür, muss ich sagen. Ich finde das super. Also man merkt dann auch,
dass ihr da auch immer gut mitdenkt.
So war das ja auch gedacht.
Christian Berger schreibt, also meine Befürchtung bei der Nutzung von KI beim
Programmieren ist, dass das falsche Problem gelöst wird.
Das Problem beim Programmieren ist ja nicht, möglichst viel Programmcode zu
erstellen, sondern ein Problem mit möglichst wenig und simplen Programmcode zu lösen.
Ich habe noch mehr geschrieben, aber ich habe das mal rausgenommen, weil,
Es gibt da, glaube ich, auch noch eine falsche Wahrnehmung.
Also man denkt derzeit so, ah ja, diese Coding Assistants sind jetzt nur dafür
da, das ganze Programm zu schreiben oder so.
Und wer das mal gemacht hat, also das kann man zwar so für kleine Dinge tun,
aber das ist eigentlich nicht wirklich, nicht das eigentliche Kernthema.
Und hat schon recht, also es geht nicht darum viel Code zu erzeugen,
sondern man will halt ein Problem lösen und das auch möglichst simpel lösen
und da kann so ein Toolset auf jeden Fall eine Unterstützung sein,
aber wie immer bei allen Tools man muss es eben auch beherrschen können.
Dann gab es noch einen Kommentar von dem Username des Monats.
Porno Pro DuSend Und wir setzen bei uns in der Firma KI selektiv in unseren
Projekten ein und nutzen dafür angepasste GPTs.
Der KI wird also zunächst beigebracht, wie sie bestimmte Probleme zu lösen hat.
Dann kann man ja das Konzept, das der Berater beschrieben hat,
geben und erhält beispielsweise die benötigten Datenbankänderungen oder Unit-Tests.
Das funktioniert gut und beschleunigt die Programmierung.
Die KI hat das Konzept eben viel schneller gelesen und entsprechenden Code nach
Vorgabe erstellt, als ich das könnte.
Selbst wenn im Konzept eine Datenbanktabelle genau beschrieben wäre,
würde ich länger als die KI brauchen und seien es nur fünf Minuten.
Aber das ist gar nicht notwendig, weil beispielsweise Datentypen aufgrund des
Allgemeinwissens des GPTs korrekt ermittelt werden.
Das ist jetzt schon so ein bisschen die advanced Anwendung dann auch.
Nicht einfach nur so reinreden in den Chat und dann kommt das Richtige bei raus,
sondern man geht da mehrstufig rum, benutzt das wirklich so als Werkzeug,
trainiert das auch nochmal auf die eigenen Anforderungen etc.
Weiter schreibt er, allgemeines Programmieren mag da mehr Probleme bereiten.
Mir reicht es oft, dass ich alternative Implementierungsideen durch den Quelltext,
den die KI erzeugt hat, erhalte. Das ist auch ein guter Punkt.
Also man muss ja noch nicht mal alles übernehmen, aber einfach so verschiedene
Ansätze mal zu exploren.
Wie könnte man das lösen? Diese Variante, diese Variante, diese Variante.
Man kommt also auch einfach dadurch auf super Ideen.
Dann schreibt er, Code kommentieren funktioniert für mich auch recht gut.
Den fertigen Code gebe ich der KI und bekomme ihn mit Kommentaren zurück,
spart auch Zeit und wenn ich Methoden ändere, fehlt nicht nachher der zusätzlich
eingebaute Parameter oder ein vorher richtiger Kommentar ist auf einmal irreführend.
Ganz wichtiger Punkt, gut dokumentierter Code ist eh eine ganze Menge wert oder
überhaupt auch so Zusammenfassungen, im Prinzip auch fertige Dokumentationen
von Änderungen oder auch Plänen, was man so vorhat.
Dass möglichst wenig der richtige Ansatz ist, glaube ich nicht.
Gut les- und wartbarer Code ist nicht unbedingt wenig Code.
Performanter Code ist nicht unbedingt wenig Code, aber mit Sicherheit kann man
eine KI auch anweisen, mit möglichst wenig und einfachem Code auszukommen.
Wichtig finde ich, dass ich den Code verstehe, den eine KI oder irgendein anderes Tool erzeugt.
Ja, also hier auch mal andere, es kann natürlich auch viel Code sein,
aber er muss halt verstanden werden können.
Das ist absolut richtig.
Last but not least, KI wird in Zukunft wohl kaum schlechter werden oder stagnieren.
Was sie heute noch nicht kann, wird sie vielleicht bald schon sehr gut können.
Man sollte sich damit auseinandersetzen, weil es nicht irgendwann Puff macht
und es keine KIs mehr gibt.
Obwohl, könnte schon passieren, ob es dann noch Menschen gibt?
Naja, das wird dann erst nach den goldenen Zwanzigern passieren.
Wissen mal, Golden 20er ist der entscheidende,
Schaltpunkt der Zukunft überhaupt.
Ich muss sagen, ich fand diesen Hinweis mit dem, es geht ja nicht darum,
möglichst viel Code zu schreiben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das so herkam.
Ich war da so ein bisschen drüber, aber der Kommentar ist ein bisschen überrascht.
Weil es ist eigentlich keine Optimierungsdimension, ob man jetzt viel oder wenig
Code schreibt, sondern dass man Probleme möglichst vernünftig löst.
Aber ich habe auch tatsächlich zu wenig Erfahrung damit, ob die Dinger zu Logorö
leiden, also ineffizientem Code oder effizienterem Code. Dafür habe ich das zu wenig benutzt.
Oder für zu kleine Probleme benutzt, um da die Effizienz am Ende beurteilen zu können.
Das ist ja auch nicht nur so eine Maschine, die du einfach anstellst und dann
kommt da einfach Software raus, sondern du musst das ja auch,
Du musst ja, das Schöne an diesen Machine Learning Sachen ist,
du hast es ja mit so einem neuronalen Netzwerk zu tun.
Und wie beim Menschen musst du halt auch erstmal die richtigen Bereiche triggern.
Also wie es für uns wichtig ist, richtige Umgebung zu haben,
gute Luft und dann die beste Musik und Inspiration und Schönheit und Kunst um
uns herum, damit unser Hirn auch entsprechend in einen kreativen Modus gebracht
wird. So ist es hier halt auch ein bisschen.
Man beschreibt halt auch erstmal, wo man hin will, wovon man ausgeht.
Das kann sehr lyrisch sein und dann möglichst eben auch relativ klar.
Worauf man hinaus haben will.
Und dann triggert man eben in diesen Systemen die entsprechenden Aktionsmuster,
die dann letzten Endes auch ein Ergebnis liefern.
Am Ende muss man sich den Code natürlich auch anschauen und reviewen sozusagen
in dem Moment und sagen, okay passt schon oder gefällt mir nicht.
Also ich habe auch sehr viel Code, der mir vorgeschlagen wird.
Da sage ich halt einfach, Alter, jetzt hast du dich einfach mal komplett verrannt.
Das führt hier nirgends wohin.
Du hast jetzt hier irgendwie auch zu viel geändert und das geht jetzt nicht
und dann wird halt alles wieder weggeschmissen.
Letzter Kommentar zu dem Blog von Chris.
Beim Thema KI habe ich als Softwareentwickler keine Angst, dass ich in naher
Zukunft ersetzt werde. Ich nutze KI ausgiebig und sehe es als sehr gutes Werkzeug.
Wir sind und werden noch eine Weile in der Phase sein, in der wir herausfinden
müssen, wie dieses Werkzeug am besten einzusetzen ist.
KI kann sehr viel ersetzen, was heutzutage jeder Junior erledigt.
Der Junior von morgen nutzt KI und löst komplexere Aufgaben bzw.
Quantitativ mehr Aufgaben. KI hat aber auch eine Schwäche, die schwer herauszubekommen ist.
Das Ergebnis basiert auf den eingegebenen Daten beziehungsweise dem eingegebenen
Wissen. In alten historischen Softwareprojekten ist diese Datenbasis ein Mix
aus guten und schlechten Bestandteilen.
Die Kunst ist es nun der KI beizubringen, diese beiden voneinander zu trennen.
Das kann beliebig komplex werden.
Je mehr KI-generierte Software dann auf KI-generierter Software basiert,
verschlimmert sich das Problem.
Das ist im Prinzip jetzt wieder genau das, was wir schon besprochen haben hier
mit so dem ganzen BSE-Problem in die Kühe sich selber.
Das würde ich schon noch irgendwie sehen, das Problem ehrlich gesagt.
Ja klar, das kann ein Problem sein.
Ob es eins werden wird, da weiß ich nicht, bin mir nicht ganz so sicher,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall etwas, womit man rechnen muss.
Unsere Aufgabe wird es also immer mehr zu entscheiden, ob das KI-Ergebnis eine
korrekte Lösung für das gegebene Problem ist. Dafür müssen wir immer noch das
Problem und die Lösung verstehen.
Die Lösung kann natürlich auch ein Programm sein, dessen Quellcode ich nicht mehr lese.
Dann muss ich irgendwie anders entscheiden, ob die Lösung korrekt ist.
Besonders der Beruf Softwareentwickler war schon immer vom schnellen Wandel betroffen.
In der Ausbildung und im Studium habe ich Dinge gelernt, die direkt danach komplett obsolet geworden sind.
Wir mussten uns schon immer stetig anpassen und das ist mit KI nichts anderes.
Mhm.
Das ist auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ja.
Stimmt.
Woran mussten sich Programmierer, dann kam die Cloud. Nee, aber es stimmt,
es ist wirklich so, dass man den Job, das Programmieren, wenn du das irgendwie
ein Jahr nicht machst, dann haben sich wirklich enorm viele Dinge geändert.
Und das ist schon wirklich tatsächlich etwas, wo man sich immer wieder mit neuen….
Und in gewisser Hinsicht, das ist jetzt auch so ein Besinnen auf die eigentlichen
Programmiertugenden, weil oft wurde man ja quasi, also Programmierer werden
ja wahrgenommen als Codeschreiber und sozusagen, ne,
dieser klassische Witz, der Programmierer sitzt vorm Rechner und tippt ja gar
nicht. Du tippst ja gar nichts ein.
Denksam denken.
Du tust ja nichts. Die eigentliche Leistung ist ja, wie das jetzt hier auch
schon mehrfach korrekt beschrieben wurde, das Problem verstehen und dafür eine Lösung anstreben.
Und diese Tools können helfen, aber ersetzen, das, ja, nicht im eigentlichen Sinne.
Aber eine extrem gute Hilfe kann es auf jeden Fall sein. Na gut, so viel dazu noch.
Dann, äh, gab es natürlich noch die Nachfrage zum Thema Ressourcenverbrauch.
Mythen des Alltags schreibt, absolut gar nicht angesprochen wurden die Implikationen
durch eskalierenden Ressourcenverbrauch bei weiterem Rollout und der direkte
Zielkonflikt mit der Transformation weg von einer primär fossilen Energieerzeugung, Notstromaggregate,
Kunststoffe, Ressourcen zur Bebauung, Kühlmittel, Feuerlöschmittel und so weiter.
Hier kann man erstmal die Frage stellen, ist es uns das wert?
In welchen Anwendungsbereichen wäre der Einsatz gerechtfertigt.
Ich finde diese Frage ganz gut.
Weil sie ja sehr unterschiedlich beantwortet wird in sehr unterschiedlichen Bereichen.
Also ist es uns das wert? Wir machen eine ganze Menge Dinge als Gesellschaft,
wenn man sich den Ressourcenverbrauch anschaut,
wo wir enorm viele Ressourcen für verhältnismäßig wenig, was man dafür wirklich bekommt, verballern.
Oder wo man sagen könnte, naja, okay,
Flugverkehr, diese ganzen Autos, die überall rumfahren, die zu einem massenhaften
Problem werden, für die Städte, für die Menschen, für die Leute,
die davon überfahren werden, für die Leute, die in den Autos sitzen, immer fetter werden.
Es ist wirklich keine positive Entwicklung, dieser riesige Verbrenner-Individualverkehr.
Trotzdem haben wir ja als Gesellschaft offensichtlich die Frage,
ist es uns das wert, mit absolut ja beantwortet und uns darauf eingerichtet,
dass unsere ganzen Städte so gebaut werden.
Und insofern würde ich sagen, dass sich diese Frage, ist es uns das wert,
erstens nicht nur rational beantwortet wird.
Zweitens würde ich aber bei dieser AI-Geschichte schon denken,
dass sie unter einem ziemlich, ziemlich großen Druck steht, auch in irgendeiner
Weise einen den Kosten entsprechenden Mehrwert irgendwo zu ermöglichen,
damit es irgendjemand nutzen wird.
Also diese Frage, ist es uns das wert, wird beantwortet, werden da,
wo Leute sagen, alles klar, wir bezahlen das. Ich möchte das haben.
Also aktuell ist es eine Wachstumstechnologie und eine Zukunftstechnologie,
wo viele um Marktanteil kämpfen.
Und irgendwann, die diesen Marktanteil haben, hoffen, oder was heißt hoffen,
die sind wahrscheinlich absolut sicher,
dass sie das gewinnbringend anbieten können und dass sie es gewinnbringend anbieten
können, weil sie da mit anderen einen Mehrwert schaffen, der höher ist.
Und wenn sie das nicht tun, dann wird diese ganze Sache in sich zusammenfallen.
Und deswegen fürchte ich,
dass die Antwort auf diese Frage, ist es uns das wert, eben von mehreren Leuten
gefunden wird und nicht notwendigerweise rational und reflektiert.
Aber würde mit dieser Technologie am Ende nicht ein vor allem wirtschaftlicher
Mehrwert für Nutzerinnen geschaffen werden,
der sich in irgendeiner Weise auch monetarisieren lässt und damit sind wir im
Zweifelsfall dann eben bei wirtschaftlichen Anwendungen.
Werden Unternehmen dank KI effizienter, besser, weiß ich nicht,
was auch immer, dass sie sagen, wir geben für KI so und so viel Geld aus?
Oder dass sie sagen, nee, ist in Ordnung, wir kommen auch ohne klar und sind
ohne konkurrenzfähig zu denen, die diese Technologie nutzen?
Also ich meine, ich finde das interessant, dass sich das jetzt sozusagen an
diesem KI-Thema so entzündet, weil Datencenter, Cloud etc.
Sind ja nun ohnehin schon Infrastrukturen, die überall auf diesem Planeten errichtet
werden, die auch Energie benötigen.
Wobei man sagen muss.
Ja aber das ist nochmal etwas andere Größenordnungen also Meta,
bemüht sich doch jetzt irgendwie um den Kauf von Atomkraftwerken also das ist
schon ein Rechenzentrum ja
braucht Energie ein Rechenzentrum mit irgendwie KI-Hochleistungsheizungen,
drin braucht schon nochmal ein bisschen mehr.
Ja aber salopp gesagt solange das nur Strom ist, den kann man ja erzeugen.
Also entweder, indem man ein Atomkraftwerk noch ein paar Jahre länger laufen lässt.
In dem Fall bei Meta ist das ja sozusagen kein neues Atomkraftwerk,
was gebaut wird, sondern eins, was länger betrieben wird, weil Meta quasi den Betrieb bezahlt.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, auch eher eine Ausnahme und so ein bisschen dieser
Geschwindigkeit, die wir jetzt gerade sehen, dieser Investitionsgeschwindigkeit geschuldet.
Langfristig muss ich das natürlich auch bezahlen und das Einzige,
was sich bezahlen lässt, ist halt einfach moderne Energieerzeugung.
Also es gibt nichts Billigeres als Solarstrom und Windstrom.
Nicht nur auf lange Sicht, sondern mittlerweile ist es ja definitiv die billigste
Möglichkeit Strom zu erstellen und deswegen wird es dann damit auch getan werden.
Die Konservativen aufhören sich dagegen in die Zukunft zu wehren natürlich.
Ja, ist natürlich richtig, aber jetzt stellt sich ja trotzdem die Frage.
Ob es uns das wert ist.
Also egal wie gut und wie billig Energie in Zukunft generiert werden kann,
wird sie trotzdem limitiert sein.
Ja, da gehe ich schon noch erstmal von aus.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn man sich so die Zuwachsraten anschaut, jetzt in der Energieerzeugung
und alleine in China, also ich glaube nicht, dass das so ein bisschen der limitierende Faktor ist.
Das ist eher das ganze fossile Zeug, was wirklich sich sehr in diesen Planeten reinfrisst.
Und da muss man sich sehr viel mehr über seinen Plastikverbrauch Gedanken machen, glaube ich.
Und es gibt so viele Bereiche, wo wir auch sehr verschwenderisch umgehen.
Das jetzt nur an diesen Datenzentren festzumachen, ist mir ein bisschen zu einfach,
weil ich da auch noch sehr viel Optimierungspotenzial sehe.
Ja, das mag sein, dass da jetzt gerade verhältnismäßig viel zusätzlicher Energieaufwand
in Auftrag gegeben wird, aber ich bin mir gar nicht mal so sicher, ob das so bleiben wird,
beziehungsweise ob es wirklich so schwierig ist, diese Energiemengen dann entsprechend
auch erzeugen zu können, ohne dass es den Planeten umbringt.
Also ich bin da einfach nicht ganz so sensibilisiert. Also ich sehe da jetzt
nicht unbedingt den Weltuntergang ausgelöst dadurch.
Das hätte man sich bei Bitcoin auch schon fragen können.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, bei Bitcoin war ja auch Bitcoin als Idee des, also und,
Zumindest, Bitcoin ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes Beispiel,
weil man ja auch sagen könnte, ist es uns das wert?
Offensichtlich wird von genug Menschen diese Frage mit Ja beantwortet.
Also wir haben einen unglaublichen Energieverbrauch durch Bitcoin,
die ganze Energie ist weg, das ist einfach nur zum Erhalt dieses Netzwerkes.
Kann man jetzt auch wieder lange Diskussionen darüber führen,
ob das in einem angemessenen Verhältnis steht zu der Anzahl Transaktionen,
die darüber abgebildet werden. Da gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen.
Ich halte das nicht für ein besonders effizientes Thema.
Überhaupt nicht.
Ja, aber trotzdem ist es so, dass sehr offensichtlich genug Menschen die Meinung oder die Frage nach,
ist es uns das wert, mit Ja beantworten.
Ja, genug Menschen, um keine Gesetze dagegen zu erlassen,
weil du halt einfach Einzelglücksritter hast,
die da so viel Geld machen, dass sie ausreichend in der Lage sind,
die Politik zu schmieren und sogar den Präsidenten der USA zu überreden,
bei diesen ganzen Betrugsmechanismen mitzumachen,
der seine eigenen Coins rausgibt und das ist genau der gleiche Scam wie der ganze andere Rest auch.
Also da kann ich halt auch die Frage schnell beantworten.
Sollte es uns das wert sein? Auf gar keinen Fall sollte es uns das wert sein,
weil es überhaupt gar keinen Nutzen gibt für diese Gesellschaft.
Also mit Bitcoin und diesen ganzen elektronischen Zahlungsträumen ist nichts
besser geworden. Seit 15 Jahren, das hat auf nichts irgendeinen positiven Einfluss.
Es hat aber sehr viel negativen Einfluss.
Und das muss einem auch klar sein in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Das sind alles so feuchte Träume, so libertäre Träume, dass dadurch irgendwie
das Finanzwesen gerechter wird.
Unsinn. Das ist einfach Quatsch. Ich werde nicht müde, das zu betonen.
Das ist einfach eine Infrastruktur für Betrug und Terrorfinanzierung.
Das ist eigentlich alles.
Das ist ja richtig, aber um beim Kommentar zu bleiben, die Frage ist ja,
wird denn jetzt mit AI was unbedingt Besseres gebaut?
Und ich denke, man kann da auf jeden Fall einen Blick drauf werfen und sagen,
wahrscheinlich steht noch der Beleg aus, dass damit jetzt ausgerechnet etwas
Positiveres gebaut wird.
Und das finde ich schon erstmal, die Frage kann man doch erstmal so stehen lassen.
Die kann man auch beantworten. Ja, also.
Also ich meine, während der Nutzen von Kryptowährungen nach wie vor nicht belegt
werden kann, aber sehr klar der negative Einfluss, ist das halt hier anders.
Also es mag jetzt negative Aspekte geben, ganz klar in diesem AI-Kram,
da haben wir auch schon viel drüber gesprochen, da können wir auch noch viel drüber sprechen.
Ja, was jetzt die, was weiß ich, wenn jetzt hier dieser Volltrottel von Gesundheitsminister
in den USA sich mit JGPT irgendwelche Studien erfinden lässt,
die irgendwie seine Anti-Impfstoff-Agenda unterstützen,
das ist natürlich ein Problem.
Fake News und all die Fälschungen und so weiter, ich will das auch überhaupt
nicht in Abrede stellen, aber die,
Wahrnehmung, dass es sich jetzt hierbei nur um irgendeinen totalen Scam halten würde,
das ist einfach Quatsch und das mit dem Programmieren, das hatten wir jetzt
schon ausreichend besprochen, wir werden auch gleich nochmal was zur Forschung
sagen, da passiert einfach viel
und sicherlich werden nicht heute alle Ergebnisse geliefert und man kann,
viele, ah guck mal hier, das war aber total scheiße und hier hat es uns irgendwie
in die Irre halluziniert.
Gibt es sicherlich viele Beispiele, aber das wird halt nicht unbedingt so bleiben
und auch gibt es genug positive Beispiele und das ist der große Unterschied,
wenn man jetzt diese beiden Systeme miteinander vergleicht.
Ich glaube, dass das jetzt, okay, in Ordnung, gut. Wir haben den Kommentar behandelt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das AI-Cool-Aid getrunken und bin total beeinflusst
von irgendwelchen bösen Kräften.
Die Frage ist doch, ist es uns das wert, in welchen Anwendungsbereichen wäre
der Einsatz gerechtfertigt?
Bisher ist doch schon, denke ich, sehr offensichtlich, dass dem,
den Ressourcen und dem Geld, was bisher in AI investiert wurde,
kein angemessener Mehrwert entgegensteht. Bisher.
Also das ist, glaube ich, absolut unstrittig. Sonst würde ja jemand damit das
Geld verdienen, was gerade alle da rein investieren. Das passiert ja nicht.
Also aktuell wird das alles entwickelt. Da wird unglaublich investiert und es
wird noch kein angemessener Mehrwert geschaffen,
dass irgendjemand bereit wäre, dafür jetzt schon kostendeckend zu bezahlen.
Und damit ist doch relativ klar, also völlig klar, dass es noch nicht an dem
Moment ist, dass wir hier einen entsprechenden Mehrwert generiert haben.
Dieser Moment kann kommen. Ja, und das ist ja die Frage, die hier auch gestellt
wird, in welchen Anwendungsbereichen ist es uns das am Ende wert?
Und ich denke, die ist völlig in Ordnung.
Und das wird sich, glaube ich, auch noch zeigen.
Also du nimmst jetzt sozusagen, also du löst jetzt diese Frage nur dahingehend auf so,
sind wir schon so weit, dass die Investitionen, die jetzt gerade da reingekippt
werden in diesen Abermilliarden von Volumen, dass sich die rechnen.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, gar nicht der Maßstab, weil sehr wohl gibt es jetzt
schon viele Anwendungen, wo Leute bereit sind, dafür zu bezahlen.
Also es gibt jetzt sozusagen schon ganz viele Business-Modelle,
Firmen, die mit KI-Technologie alles mögliche heute schon lösen und das auch
schon seit längerer Zeit und nicht erst seit zwei Jahren.
Und Leute sind bereit, dafür Geld zu bezahlen.
Das ist ja auch absolut richtig. Aber noch nicht in dem Ausmaß.
Und das ist doch der, schau mal, wenn man in dem Ausmaß wieder Geld investiert wird.
Also wenn du, nehmen wir Atomenergie.
Das war doch beim Internet am Anfang genauso.
Richtig. Und am Anfang hat selbst der Ron Sommer nicht absehen können.
Der weise Ron Sommer, der sagt, das Internet ist eine Spielerei für Technik,
wir sehen daran keine Zukunft.
Wer es nicht weiß, der ehemalige Chef der Telekom.
Tim, Atomenergie. Nehmen wir Atomenergie.
Warum haben wir es, warum haben wir überhaupt auf diesem Planeten Atomkraftwerke gebaut?
Weil wir Umfelder geschaffen haben, in denen die Ewigkeitskosten dieser Energienutzung
komplett aus der Wirtschaft entfernt wurden.
Du konntest Atomkraftwerke betreiben und hast am Ende gesagt,
alles klar und die ganzen Uranmüll, das ist nicht unser Problem.
Und so ist daraus ein wirtschaftlich gangbarer Weg geworden.
Ziemlich absurd, dass man so etwas macht, ähnlich übrigens mit anderen Energieformen
ja auch, die sehr stark subventioniert werden, weil man Entscheidungen trifft,
die nicht notwendigerweise rational sind.
So, hätte die Gesamtkosten für Atomenergie irgendjemand einmal tragen müssen,
dann wäre es niemals zu einer Nutzung dieser Energieform gekommen.
Das heißt, wir haben hier etwas, oder nicht in dem Ausmaß,
das heißt, wir haben gesellschaftliche Bedingungen geschaffen,
um etwas, was ökonomisch keinen
Sinn macht und auch ökologisch äußerst kritisch ist, zu ermöglichen.
Und das Argument, was du gerade machst, ist, ja, aber es wurde ja mit Atomenergie Geld verdient.
Ja, stimmt, wurde Geld mit verdient.
Aber wenn man den Gesamtnutzen rechnen würde, übrigens auch wenn man den Ausstoß
von CO2 in die Atmosphäre mit angemessenen Kosten verbinden würde,
dann hätten wir auch keine Gas- oder Kohlekraftwerke mehr.
Weil die Gesamtrechnung auf jeden Fall nicht aufgeht.
Aber je nachdem, welche Teile man jetzt reinfaktorisiert und welche nicht,
gehen so Rechnungen auf einmal doch auf.
Aber und so würde ich das Argument vergleichen, dass ja, ja,
es wird mit AI Gutes getan und es bezahlen auch Leute Geld dafür,
bisher steht das nicht in einem Verhältnis zu den Ressourcen und sonstigen Kosten,
die bisher angefallen sind.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass sich das ändern wird, ich gehe auch davon aus,
dass diese Technologie bleiben wird, aber was ja hier in dem Kommentar gefragt
wird, ist, in welchen Bereichen wenden wir sie an?
Und ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das unterschiedliche Pfade nehmen kann,
ob man, und zum Beispiel, ob man das jetzt in der Privatwirtschaft oder irgendwie
als Consumer hier jeder irgendwie so einen komischen sprechenden Assistenten
oder vielleicht dann doch nicht.
Vielleicht ist das dann doch irgendwann zu teuer und die Ressource AI zu benutzen wird,
ehrlich bepreist und ist dann
für viele Anwendungszwecke auf einmal vielleicht doch wieder zu teuer.
Weißt du, der wahre Preis von AI-Nutzung wird ja dann irgendwann mal noch kommen.
Und spätestens dann, wenn man feststellt, also irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
ich habe jetzt, also nehmen wir ChatGPT, ich habe da irgendeinen privaten Account
oder was, also für meine private Nutzung ist das irgendwie völlig in Ordnung.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die irgendwann einmal sagen,
pass auf, gewerbliche Nutzung oder berufliche Nutzung, da haben wir jetzt einen anderen Preis für.
Und um so natürlich auch zu versuchen, die,
Nutzung dahin zu kanalisieren, wo sie Geld verdienen, wo es für andere Mehrwert
schafft und da dann aber natürlich auch einen Teil des Mehrwerts,
den diese Technologie schafft, in irgendeiner Weise wieder abzuschöpfen.
Und das glaube ich, Da wird dann die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes plus der Subventionen,
plus der Irrationalität,
was Staaten jetzt gerade noch da reinbauen und das auch subventionieren,
da wird der Planet dann hingelenkt.
Wäre so meine Schätzung.
In den beiden Fragen ist, ist es uns das wert und in welchen Anwendungsbereichen
wäre der Einsatz gerechtfertigt?
Da kann ich nur sagen, also offensichtlich ist es uns das wert,
weil das halt einfach wie Computeralgorithmen als solche haben wir jetzt sozusagen
die Next Level von Algorithmen und das wird sich einfach auf alles mögliche anwenden lassen.
Und in welchen Anwendungsbereichen wäre der Einsatz gerechtfertigt?
Ja, wahrscheinlich in allen. Also zumindest in den allermeisten.
Dann ging es in dein Berufsfeld über. Da halte ich mal raus.
Also ich hatte ja darüber gesprochen, dass ich davon ausgehe,
dass der Bereich der Psychotherapie durch KI-Modelle sehr stark verändert werden wird.
Und das hat unterschiedlichste Reaktionen herausgekitzelt. ähm.
Eine sehr wichtige hatte ich bei Enno Park gelesen auf Mastodon,
der dann zum Beispiel auch sagte, naja, macht sich eigentlich bei dieser Aussage
niemand darüber Gedanken, wenn dann alle,
also beispielsweise ihre Psychotherapie jetzt mit ChatGPT machen,
was für Inhalte dann da gerade an OpenAI geliefert werden. Da müssen ja alle durchdrehen.
Und das ist natürlich, das fand ich eigentlich, finde ich, noch den wichtigsten
Aspekt an der ganzen Sache.
Und gleichzeitig ist die Historie der Chatbots, fängt mit Elisa an,
mit der Idee, einen Gesprächstherapeuten in einem einfachen Programm zu simulieren.
Warum ich aber davon ausgehe, und jetzt kommen wir erstmal zu den Kommentaren,
also es kommentiert, Sandra sagt, zum Thema KI in der Psychotherapie wurde ja
schon einiges gesagt, zumindest in der Verhaltenstherapie sagt die Studienlage relativ deutlich,
dass einer der wichtigsten Faktoren für den positiven Verlauf einer Therapie
die Beziehung zwischen Patientin und Therapeutin ist.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass eine KI das kurzfristig ersetzen kann.
Außerdem birgt das durchaus Gefahren. Die aktuellen Modelle reden einem ja vor
allem nach dem Mund und stimmen erstmal immer zu, was auch immer man sagt.
Es gibt vermehrt Berichte von Personen, die sicherlich auch mit entsprechender
Prädisposition regelrechte Psychosen entwickeln durch die Nutzung von Chat, GPT und Co.
Zwei Punkte, zu denen ich da gerne was sagen würde.
Es stimmt, Verlauf einer Therapie ist maßgeblich auch durch die Passung von
Patientin und Therapeutin geprägt.
Vorhergesagt oder mitbestimmt.
Jetzt überleg mal, wie schwierig das Potenzial ist, unter echten Menschen jemanden
mit der richtigen Passung zu finden. Deswegen ist das ja auch ein großes Problem.
Aber meine These wäre, dass die Passung zwischen Patientin und Therapeutin ein
entscheidender Faktor daran liegt, liegt nicht daran, dass die Passung gut sein
muss, sondern wie oft sie schlecht ist.
Und ein darauf ausgelegtes Modell, glaube ich, könnte mit höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit
eine Passung zu einem Menschen finden.
Zumindest sagen die wenigsten Leute, dass ihnen Chat-GPT irgendwie unsympathisch ist.
Also ich glaube, dass dieser Fakt eigentlich in der Interpretation genau umgedreht ist,
nämlich die Passung musst du erstmal bei Menschen finden und bei einem Modell
kannst du die potenziell einstellen.
Dann, ja, die aktuellen Modelle reden einem nach dem Mund, schaffen die Leute
Psychosen und so weiter.
Die sind aber auch noch nicht auf Psychotherapie trainiert worden.
Ja, das sind ja keine spezialisierten Modelle. Womit wir bei dem dritten Punkt
wären, komme ich zurück zu dem Post von Enno.
Also sicherlich wäre es so,
dass in einer für Therapie tatsächlich zugelassenen KI sehr strenge Regelungen gelten würden,
von wem die betrieben werden darf, dass sie überhaupt verschrieben werden kann
und so weiter, dass sie am Ende Diagnostik machen kann oder so.
Da würde sicherlich noch eine Menge passieren.
Was ich mir aber durchaus zum Beispiel vorstellen kann, ist,
dass man das quasi auch eine Therapie ergänzt.
Dass du quasi nicht mehr nur einmal oder zweimal die Woche oder einmal alle
zwei Wochen zu deiner Therapeutin gehst, dann eine Dreiviertelstunde mit der
Rede ist und man davon ausgeht, dass dieses eine Gespräch,
jetzt irgendwie einen nachhaltigen Effekt bis zur nächsten Therapiesitzung haben wird.
Wir hatten ja eingangs schon ein bisschen darüber gesprochen,
es spielt halt schon eine Rolle, womit Menschen sich täglich befassen und wo
ihre Aufmerksamkeit ist.
Und selbst wenn so eine super passende Therapeutin mit einer Sitzung die Woche
dich maßgeblich zum Denken anregt.
Hätte ein Chatbot mit einer vielleicht nicht ganz so guten Passung,
aber zumindest keiner Antipathie, potenziell sehr, sehr viel mehr Zeit auf dich einzuwirken.
Und da würde ich dann schon davon ausgehen, dass es ...
Dass es hier am Ende einen positiven Effekt geben kann.
Oder zumindest einen ergänzenden, dass man sagt, keine Ahnung,
jede Woche Therapie und den Rest der Zeit muss ich 20 Minuten pro Tag nochmal
mit dem Chatbot sprechen oder so. Der passt auch auf, dass ich meine Therapiehausaufgaben mache.
Ich bin mir absolut sicher, dass dieser Bereich davon beeinflusst wird und dadurch besser werden wird.
Lealexandra, Lealexandra oder was? Zum Thema Psychotherapie hat Linus gesagt,
dass diese idealerweise nach evidenzbasierten Manualen stattfindet.
Das ist für die Verhaltenstherapie im Prinzip richtig, allerdings muss ich aus
eigener Erfahrung berichten und ich habe dies von Kolleginnen ebenfalls gehört,
dass es selten möglich ist, eine manualisierte Therapie nach Plan durchzuziehen,
da ja die meisten Patientinnen zwischen den Sitzungen viel erleben und sich
auch die generelle Problemlage ständig ändern kann.
Da muss man als Therapeutin oft improvisieren können und ad hoc überlegen,
was denn in der neuen Situation sinnvoll wäre.
Es geht also um situative Flexibilität.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob KI dies so leisten könnte. Ähm.
Da würde ich jetzt erstmal kurz eine Pause machen. Ich lese den Kommentar gleich weiter vor.
Ich denke, auch hier ist die Antwort ja schon drin.
Zwischen den Sitzungen kann sich viel ändern. Die Leute erleben viel zwischen
den Sitzungen. Klar, die Therapie geht über Monate zwischendurch.
Was weiß ich, erkrankt ein Familienmitglied oder du gewinnst im Lotto oder so.
Da ändern sich ja Faktoren.
Wetter ändert sich, deine Winterdepression ist weg. Was auch alles.
Klar, muss die Therapeutin alles drauf reagieren. Aber da ist doch auch ein
täglich verfügbarer Chatbot in einer besseren Ausgangslage.
Und vor allem auf unterschiedliche Situationen zu reagieren.
Also Chat-GPT kann ich zu allem fragen, kann ich auch ein Rezept noch erfragen.
Zudem gibt es Studien, die belegen, dass die Therapieform,
also Verhaltenstherapie und so weiter und die Inhalte, Cognitive Behavioral
Therapy, wohl weniger oder höchstens genauso relevant sind hinsichtlich Therapieerfolg
als bestimmte Merkmale, Fähigkeiten der Therapeutin hinsichtlich Empathie, Wertschätzung.
Auch Humor in der Psychotherapie hat sich als ein wirksames Mittel erwiesen.
Und da es jetzt schon Kolleginnen gibt, die sich mit dem Einsatz von Humor schwer
tun, bin ich nicht sicher, wie gut das mit KI laufen würde.
Ebenso was echte Empathie, Wertschätzung und so weiter betrifft.
Da bin ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so von überzeugt.
Das ist ja genau das gleiche Argument, Passung oder Fähigkeit der Therapeutin.
Empathie, Humor, also all das,
glaube ich, kann ein Chatbot für einen längeren Zeitraum aufrechterhalten und
liefern als ein Mensch und streckenweise vielleicht sogar besser.
Insofern, das Einzige, was am Ende wirklich fehlt, sind die Möglichkeiten des
Chatbots durch nonverbale Cues, das auch zu vermitteln.
Aber ich glaube, da unterschätzen wir, wie einfach sich diese menschlichen Gefühle auch triggern lassen.
Also dann machst du dem Ding halt ein Gesicht und das Gesicht lächelt halt und
guckt traurig, wenn du was Trauriges erzählst und guckt, lacht mit dir oder
macht mal einen Witz und vermittelt dir Emotionen.
Wir reagieren als Menschen auf sowas. Wir reagieren ja auch zum Beispiel,
wir gehen in ein Kino und da sind Zeichentrickfiguren, das sind auch nicht mal
Menschen. Wir wissen, die gibt es nicht.
Und wenn die sich ein Bein brechen, dann haben wir ein Mitgefühl mit denen.
Ein blöder Smiley in einer WhatsApp-Nachricht löst in uns Emotionen aus.
Da wird ein Chatbot das nicht schwer haben, das auch wohldosiert zu triggern.
Also ich glaube, am Ende haben wir die Frage,
wie oft können unsere Gedanken an therapeutische Inhalte gebracht werden und
was wir noch gar nicht in dem, und da hat der Chatbot eben halt gegenüber den
45 Minuten normale Therapiesitzung einfach einen massiven Vorteil.
Und der kann potenzielle Nachteile einfach durch Zeit wahrscheinlich ausgleichen. So meine These.
Und dann haben wir noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen, dass es auch eine ganze
Reihe Störungsbilder gibt, wo allein das sich zu Therapeutinnen bewegen ein riesiges Problem ist.
Also Depression und Agoraphobie sind jetzt nur mal so einfache Beispiele.
Wer US-Podcasts hört, dem bluten wahrscheinlich auch schon die Ohren von dieser
Therapie-App-Werbung.
Also da gibt es ja schon jetzt eine App in den USA, die, ich glaube,
die nennt sich BetterHelp oder sowas, wo du im Prinzip mal eben so spontan so
eine Therapeutin herbeitindern kannst oder so.
Und wenn dir die nicht gefällt, dann swipes du die weg und nimmst eine andere.
Und da werden Menschen ja heute schon dran gewöhnt, mit Menschen.
Also echte Therapeuten oder AI-Therapeuten werden einem vermittelt.
Ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass das echte Therapeuten sind zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt.
So hört sich das zumindest an. Gibt es übrigens auch in Deutsch.
Kein Zeitplan, keine Therapie, kein Wartezimmer.
27.000 lizenzierte Therapeutinnen arbeiten dort mit.
Wahrscheinlich so Freelancer, Nebenjob oder sowas, was du da machen kannst.
Eine Nachfrage dazu. Meinst du nicht auch,
dass in diesem Vertrauensverhältnis, was man dann quasi als Therapierender gegenüber
so einem Therapeuten ja haben muss, damit es für einen einen Wert darstellt,
spielt da nicht einerseits so eine als echt empfundene Empathie eine Rolle?
Dass man sozusagen das Gefühl hat, diese Person ist wirklich daran interessiert, mir zu helfen.
Wo man halt sagen kann, naja, so ein Chatbot, der ist halt drauf programmiert,
hier immer so rüber zu kommen, meint es ja eigentlich gar nicht so.
Ja, die Therapeutin doch auch. Ich meine, also die ist doch auch, also stell dir mal vor,
also ich habe ja Psychologie studiert und es war auch meine Vorstellung,
dass ich Therapeut werden würde. Oder meine Idee.
Könnte auch sagen, du bist es geworden.
Also ich bin heilfroh, dass mir dann irgendwann eine der Therapeutinnen,
die da an der Uni gelehrt hat, mir auch vermittelt hat, dass das kein Job für mich ist.
Also ich also stell dir mal die Herausforderung vor, die ist jetzt wirklich,
ernsthaft du sitzt da, dein Arbeitstag ist, da kommt jede Stunde jemand rein,
und labert dich mit irgendeinem Problem vor, für das du die Lösung kennst und.
Du musst alles, was die dir erzählen egal wie bescheuert das vielleicht manchmal
ist oder vielleicht auch, dass die vielleicht Inhalte äußern,
Dann äußern die sich vielleicht rassistisch oder sowas.
Und dann musst du ja trotzdem wertschätzend mit denen weiter umgehen.
Und jetzt überleg mal, wenn dir das wirklich nah ginge,
was das für ein fürchterlicher Albtraumjob ist, wenn du dann diese ganzen Patientinnen
hast und dieses ganze Leid von denen die ganze Zeit vertikutieren und spiegeln und empfinden musst.
Und dann geht es dir wirklich nah, das
ist ja dann, also du musst ja eine professionelle Distanz dazu aufbauen.
Und diesen Modus lernen.
Sonst richtet dich ja dieser Job zugrunde.
Ja gut, aber nochmal aus der anderen Perspektive, worauf ich eigentlich so ein
bisschen hinaus wollte, ist so dieses Misstrauen in solche Systeme.
Man kennt ja aus der Computergrafik diesen Begriff des Uncanny Valley,
wenn so eine dreidimensionale Darstellung eines in der Regel Menschen so kurz
vor der Perfektion ist und dann die Akzeptanz bei den Menschen auf einmal so
total in den Keller geht.
Also bis 80%, 90%, 95% Ähnlichkeit mit einem Menschen ist irgendwie noch alles okay,
aber man akzeptiert diesen Unterschied, aber in dem Moment, wo es dann zu nah
rankommt, dann reißt auf einmal diese Akzeptanz extrem ein, weil es einem dann creepy vorkommt.
Weil man dann auf einmal dieses Vertrauen nicht mehr hat oder man das Gefühl
hat, dass es sich zu sehr an einen ranwanzt.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es da auf so einer psychologischen Ebene
ähnliche Effekte gibt. Das ist nur so ein Gedanke, der mir gerade gekommen ist.
Und ich bin mir sicher, dass es sehr, sehr viele solche Effekte gibt,
die alle erforscht werden und die dann eben optimiert werden.
Also, mein Argument ist ja nicht, dass es jetzt vielleicht die menschlichen
Therapeutinnen komplett ersetzt.
Die wird es schon weiterhin geben.
Mein Argument ist, das wird gut genug sein, dass man Effekte feststellt.
Das wird sich dann auch wieder unterscheiden für Art des Störungsbildes.
Also was weiß ich, hast du, keine Ahnung, Borderline-Persönlichkeitsstörung
passt dann vielleicht nicht so gut, Narzissten passt besser oder was auch immer.
Es gibt ja viele unterschiedliche Diagnosen, in die das Leid von Menschen kategorisiert wird.
Und da werden sich sicherlich unterschiedliche Dinge ergeben,
wie man jetzt zum Beispiel auch heute weiß, bei der und dem Problem machst du
eine Verhaltenstherapie, bei dem und dem Problem machst du eine Schematherapie.
Und dann wird man eben genauso. Und bei dem und dem Problem kannst du super
Erfolge haben, indem du das Ganze ergänzt oder vollständig von einem dafür gebauten App machen lässt.
Und ob die dann ein Chatbot ist oder vielleicht eine Figur oder wie die Figur
aussieht, kannst du ja wahrscheinlich dann einstellen.
Also ich glaube, alles, was ich an Einwänden oder Schwierigkeiten höre, erscheint mir lösbar.
Ja, also oh Mann, ey, das öffnet natürlich eine ganze Menge interessanter,
Erzählweisen. Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen so diese alte Science-Fiction-Vision
von so einem Total Mind Control.
Wird den Leuten noch geholfen oder wird den Leuten irgendwas eingeredet?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und es ist natürlich auch eine völlig,
irre Vorstellungen, ja, immer angenommen, es würde jetzt jemand,
und ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das passieren wird, baut jemand jetzt irgendwie
so ein Therapie-Bot, der macht
eine bestimmte Form von Therapie für eine bestimmte Form von Beschwerde,
und der hängt da irgendwo in so einem AWS-Data-Center auf seiner Grafikkarte
und redet mit weiß nicht wie vielen Leuten gleichzeitig, ja.
Und irgendwann geht was schief und dann, ja.
Da sehe ich auf jeden Fall nochmal eine ganze Menge Security-Aspekte in dem Bereich.
Aber ich glaube, dass auf dem Weg dorthin sich zu oft zu gut zeigen wird bei
jeder Studie, dass das irgendeine Wirkung hat und dass das ein Bereich ist, den man verfolgen wird.
Das kann natürlich auch zum durchautomatisierten Enkeltrick werden.
Ich meine, dass diese Systeme dann einfach wirklich maliziös geformt werden,
um Leute dazu zu bringen, ein Verhalten an den Tag zu legen,
was sie normalerweise vielleicht nicht gemacht hätten und ihre Notsituation
in der Hinsicht auch noch ausgenutzt wird, ist definitiv ein Bedrohungsszenario,
was man hier auch nochmal berücksichtigen muss.
Absolut, aber nicht nur in dem Moment, wo du sagst, das ist jetzt ein therapeutisches
Interventionsmodell, dass wir, was weiß ich, auf...
Auf Diagnose oder sonst was auf Kasse zur Anwendung bringen.
Das viel größere Problem ist doch eigentlich der privatwirtschaftliche Bereich,
wo du dann irgendwie einen Tamagotchi oder eine Freundin in so einem Ding hast.
Wir haben ja wahrscheinlich alle inzwischen den Film höher gesehen, wo das schief geht.
Wo deine persönliche Assistentin halt ein kleines bisschen zu sympathisch und
empathisch ist. und zack, bist du auf einmal irgendwie eine Stimme im Ohr verliebt.
Ja. Zu wenig in deine.
Ja, das sowieso. Ja, aber das ist ja dann eine, da ist ja dieser privatwirtschaftliche
Bereich, wo irgendwelchen Leuten irgendwas gegeben wird, der viel schlimmere,
als wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, es gehen Psychologinnen und Psychologen hin und bauen einen,
spezifisch nach manual in einem besonderen spezifischen Bereich agierendes Modell.
Gar keine Frage wird es da Modelle geben, die sagen wir mal mit dem richtigen
wissenschaftlichen Input und Herzblut designt sind.
Ich sage nur, die Privatwirtschaft wird sich dieses Themas auf jeden Fall auch
annehmen und digitale Beichtstühle schaffen, die sicherlich auch nochmal ein Money Grab sind.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall nochmal ein Bereich, den muss man sehr gut beobachten.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, dass wir in der Privatwirtschaft auf jeden Fall auf
Sorgfalt und ethische Grundprinzipien setzen können.
Okay, dann hatte noch Lupino zu KI in der Forschung eine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Woher kommt eigentlich diese Annahme, dass KI emergentes Wissen generieren könne,
also Wissen, das nicht in den Trainingsdaten enthalten war, die KI aber trotzdem
aus dem zum Training verwendeten Daten erschließen konnte?
Müssten wir dafür nicht wissen, welche Informationen nicht in den Trainingsdaten enthalten waren?
Wie können wir das wissen, wenn
mittlerweile das komplette Internet zum Training von KIs verwendet wird?
Okay, ich habe die Frage mal beantwortet. Der Fehler in dieser Frage ist,
dass das Wissen nicht in den Daten wäre.
Die Antwort auf die Frage ist, das Wissen ist in den Daten nur nicht explizit.
Und was wir bei dieser Forschung, bei diesen Forschungsthemen meinen,
ist, dass du in unstrukturierten Daten Zusammenhänge finden kannst.
Forschung bisher geht mit Regressionsanalysen, Korrelationen,
was auch immer, linealen Modellen, irgendwas hin und findet Zusammenhänge in strukturierten Daten.
Ein größerer Teil der Forschung ist, die Daten in dem Format zu haben,
dass du die Zusammenhangsmodelle und Signifikanztests machen kannst,
die du brauchst, um dein Experiment zu prüfen. Ja.
Wenn du nun einen riesigen Datenhaufen hast, in dem du gar nicht weißt,
was es alles für Zusammenhänge geben kann,
dann ist so ein neuronales Modell genau das, um diese Zusammenhänge in unstrukturierten
Daten zu finden. Und das haben die halt getan.
Das haben diese Chatbots getan.
Die haben einen Riesenhaufen unstrukturierter Daten bekommen und daraus eine
kohärente Entität geschaffen, die mehrere Sprachen spricht.
Und das wäre die Idee, warum Forschung mithilfe von solchen Modellen Zusammenhänge
findet, die die Menschheit einfach noch nicht gefunden hat.
Ja, also wie es jetzt auch schon zahlreiche Beispiele gibt aus der Medizin,
also das ist so dieses Ganze, was hat denn der Patient eigentlich, also es gibt einfach oft,
Keine Diagnose für irgendein Leiden, weil es einfach sich um ein sehr,
sehr seltenes Leiden handelt und von daher erstmal gar nicht identifiziert werden kann.
Da sind solche Systeme sicherlich hilfreich,
um das in all dem ganzen medizinischen Historien Unterlagen zu finden und diese
Korrelationen herauszufinden,
die dann vielleicht tatsächlich auf eine richtige Diagnose oder auch auf eine Medikation.
Für diesen Fall hinweisen.
Und es gibt mittlerweile einige, die sich darauf spezialisieren,
eben genau das zu tun, also mit solchen Tools Lösungen zu finden für bisher
ungelöste medizinische Fälle.
Und ein Phänomenbereich, von dem ich leider, obwohl ich schon mehrere Vorträge
darüber gehört habe, immer noch zu wenig verstehe, ist das mit der Proteinfaltung.
Also aus Gründen, die ich jetzt gerade nicht korrekt wiedergeben kann,
ist es irgendwie enorm schwer, die Regeln zu erfassen, nach denen Proteine sich falten.
Und das ist aber unbedingt notwendig, weil nur wenn du weißt,
wie die sich falten, dann kannst du sie stabil herstellen.
Und die Wege, das zu simulieren, irgendwie Folding at home und was es da alles
schon gab, die haben alle,
irgendwie Ewigkeiten ins Nichts gestoßen und die genauesten Vorhersagen macht
nach meiner Kenntnis Alpha Fold, das ist irgendein Deep Learning.
Die haben einfach irgendwelche Proteine reingeworfen, weiß der Geier, warum das so ging.
Aber deswegen kann jetzt die Proteinfaltung am besten vorhersagen und das ist halt ein,
jetzt lehne ich mich hoffentlich nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster,
aber ich würde sagen, das ist ein Prozess der Naturgesetzen gehorcht und wahrscheinlich
auch deterministisch und logisch ist, aber wir haben es einfach noch nicht vollständig erfasst.
Also es ist einfach ein super komplexes Thema. Also Proteinfaltung bedeutet
ja letztendlich, du hast halt diese Aminosäurenketten und die liegen jetzt vor.
Und wenn du die dann sozusagen ins Freie entlässt, dann falten die sich eben
automatisch zusammen auf Basis von allen möglichen physikalischen und chemischen
Vorgängen, die da halt stattfinden.
Von denen wir einfach noch nicht alle kennen.
Ja, oder selbst wenn wir sie alle kennen, die ganzen Interaktionen auf dieser
Mikroebene sind so vielfältig und so vieldimensional, du kannst das nicht vollständig simulieren.
Du kannst nicht die komplette Physik darum herum simulieren und deswegen ist
diese Vorhersage eben sehr schwierig gewesen auf einem regelbasierten Vorhersagemodell,
wie es ja jahrzehntelang versucht wurde aufzustellen.
Und es gab viele Ansätze in Software, das zu machen, die dann eben mal bis 20,
bis 30, bis 50 Prozent der Vorhersagen kamen,
bis dann eben die KI-basierten Systeme wie AlphaFold oder vor allem natürlich
AlphaFold daherkamen und einfach eine ganz andere Art der Vorhersagen gemacht
hat, die eben nicht auf Regeln basiert, sondern eben einfach nur auf der Analyse dieser Daten.
Und das hat deutlich bessere Ergebnisse erzielt und zwar extrem viel bessere Ergebnisse.
Also kleine Anmerkung, das basiert jetzt auch auf Regeln, nur das Modell kann
uns die nicht mehr sagen.
Ja genau, also nicht Regeln, die man sich jetzt so ausdenkt und jetzt implementiere
ich die in Software, sondern man nutzt eben einfach Machine Learning und diese
ganzen schon beschriebenen Systeme
und kommt dann sozusagen auf die Lösung durch einen anderen Ansatz.
Und das lässt sich ja dann belegen, weil man hat ja dann eben die Vorhersage
und man sieht auch, was da eben letzten Endes bei rauskommt und kann es eben
direkt miteinander vergleichen und deswegen gibt es da eine klare Bewertung
der Nützlichkeit an der Stelle.
Ähnliche Ergebnisse sind wahrscheinlich bei der Wettervorhersage irgendwann dann zu bezielen, oder?
Genau, also alles, was komplexe Daten sind und Vorhersagen, das wird davon enorm betroffen sein.
Und weil das dann gerne so ein bisschen in das Esoterische abdriftet,
das finde ich, also diese Sachen, das finde ich zum Beispiel in keiner Form
überraschend, Weil du diese neuronalen Modelle ja auch interpretieren kannst als riesig, riesig,
riesig multivariate Regressionsanalysen, die halt unglaubliche Komplexität an
Zusammenhängen durch Gewichtungen von Faktoren abbilden.
Und wenn du ein Modell so interpretierst,
dann ist das auf einmal relativ naheliegend, dass das ein guter Ansatz ist,
einen noch nicht vollständig ergründeten Zusammenhang von Regeln abzubilden,
indem du halt eine unglaubliche Regressionsanalyse in mehreren Layern hintereinander
machst mit tausenden von Faktoren, die sich gegenseitig beeinflussen und an
jeden einen Gewicht dran stehst.
Und dann hast du die Möglichkeit, diesen Problemraum auf einmal zu erfassen
und abzubilden und die Regeln implizit in diesen Gewichten abzubilden.
Gut, dann kommt Johannes und kommentierte zum Thema KI und Kreativität.
Als klassisch ausgebildeter Musiker kann ich sagen, dass KI in der Konzertwelt
wohl kaum die Rolle der Menschen übernehmen kann.
Das Erleben einer Performance in Fleisch und Blut lässt sich nicht technisch
ersetzen, auch wenn es humanoide Roboter gäbe, die genauso aussehen und spielen könnten wie Menschen.
Auch wenn die Maschinen alles perfekter könnten als der Mensch,
werden die menschlichen Bezugspunkte immer relevanter werden.
Genau so ist es auch im Sport. Es würde überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben,
Roboter und Fußballmannschaften gegeneinander antreten zu lassen,
macht die HU seit 20 Jahren.
Zu einer gelungenen, berührenden Performance zählt einfach immer auch der Schweiß,
die Fehler und Momente, an denen sich der Performer selbst übertrifft.
Ganz anders sieht die Sache in der medialen Sphäre aus. Filmmusik zum Beispiel
wird sehr wahrscheinlich bald fast ausschließlich AI generiert sein zum Leidwesen
aller Musiker, die von solchen Aufnahmen leben.
Ja, 100 Prozent. Das ist völlig klar.
Das ist das Live-Erlebnis, wenn Menschen Sport treiben oder Wettkämpfe verlieren.
Und das Live-Erlebnis, wenn sie wirklich in diesem Moment die Leistung des Musikspielens
erbringen, ist ungebrochen.
Aber alles, was aufgezeichnet ist, hat ja ohnehin auch schon,
und dieser Wertverlust war ja auch schon vorher da.
Also wir geben ja als Mensch halt auch immer weniger für aufgezeichnete Musik
aus, nämlich irgendwie 10, 12 Euro im Monat.
Das war sicherlich bei einigen Menschen früher sehr viel mehr,
was sie für aufgezeichnete Musik ausgegeben haben.
Das war aber auch bei einigen deutlich weniger wahrscheinlich.
Mag auch sein, ja. Und dann geht es aber noch weiter.
Ein letzter Gedanke zum Thema Originalität. Ich denke, dass AI sicherlich auf
sehr hohem Niveau imitieren und zusammenstellen kann.
Beispielsweise wie oben genannt den Stil vom alten Beethoven imitieren.
Aber AI kann nicht, was Beethoven zu seiner Zeit besonders gemacht hat,
nämlich sich immer weiterzuentwickeln und Neues zu erfinden.
Sprich, AI könnte nicht aus einem jungen Beethoven einen alten deduzieren.
Einfach, weil es in der Kunst kein Feedback im Sinne von richtig oder falsch
gibt. Es gibt also keine Regel, nach der sich Kunst in die eine oder andere
Richtung weiterentwickelt.
Wenn es jedoch einfach nur um Stilkopie geht, gibt es diese Regeln aber sehr
wohl. Deswegen kann AI das so gut.
Ja, jetzt hast du natürlich Beethoven gebracht und die zehnte Sinfonie,
die durch KI zu Ende gespielt wurde. Ja.
Da ist es tatsächlich, ich habe ja auch nochmal den Wikipedia-Artikel genommen,
die haben halt das Ding erstmal Beethoven lernen lassen,
dann von Beethoven inspirierte Musiker lernen lassen, um dem dieses,
was kann man denn da so weiterentwickeln,
beizubringen.
Und tatsächlich hatte auch diese fertige, also das haben ja sehr viele Leute,
wenn ich möchte, kann ich heute auch nochmal die 10.
Symphonie zu Ende schreiben lassen von der KI. Aber diese, die dann da aufgeführt
wurde, wo dann die Beethoven-Expertinnen gesagt haben, ja, das überzeugt mich
jetzt hier, hatte tatsächlich auch überraschende Elemente drin.
Und am Ende wurde das, hat irgendwie der Walter Werzova das orchestriert und
am Ende eine Orgel noch mit einbezogen, was glaube ich Beethoven sonst eher nicht gemacht hat.
Also da von auszugehen, dass da keine genuinen neuen Dinge oder plötzlichen
Kreativitäten und Ausreißer oder Überraschungen drin vorkommen,
das kann man dann doch relativ einfach machen.
Das ist eine Einschätzungsfrage, wie sich das technologisch auch weiterentwickeln
wird. Ich bin da selber ein bisschen gespalten.
Ich halte beides für möglich. Ich halte es für möglich, dass es schwierig bleiben
wird und vielleicht auch so ein Hard Limit nicht überschreiten kann. Kann sein.
Kann aber auch genau andersrum sein. Kann sehr wohl sein, dass wir nach langer
Forschung tatsächlich eine Methode gefunden haben,
unser Gehirn, oder nicht nur unser Gehirn, sondern generell Gehirne so gut zu
emulieren, dass wir eben auch deren.
Fähigkeiten nachbilden können. Und da gehört dann eben auch die Entwicklung
eines Bewusstseins und vielleicht eben auch die Entwicklung eines kreativen Prozesses dazu,
sofern es eben auch gelingt, entsprechende positive, negative Einflüsse der
Gesellschaft, Nachrichtenlagen, Ereignisse, Wetter,
all diese ganzen anderen Dinge, die ja unser Hirn auch mit konditionieren,
auch hier quasi mit einzubringen.
Ob das jetzt erstrebenswert ist, sei mal dahingesagt, wir reden ja auch generell
hier in dieser ganzen Debatte,
also bevor uns jetzt wieder hier als Doomsayer in der einen Richtung oder AI-Apologeten
in der anderen Richtung schimpft, wir versuchen ja auch nur hier so ein bisschen
so ein Grip zu bekommen mit okay,
was ist das, was hat das für ein Potenzial, wo geht es hin?
Manche Sachen halten wir für wahrscheinlicher, manche halten wir für unwahrscheinlicher,
da müssen wir auch nicht unbedingt recht liegen, aber es ist jetzt keine Agenda,
die wir jetzt hier irgendwie,
verfolgen, sondern wir machen uns halt einfach auch nur so unsere Gedanken über
eine Technologie, die einfach ein bisschen like no other ist,
also die sich auch schwerer vorhersagen lässt noch in ihrer Auswirkung und Vielseitigkeit
und Zukunft, als das bisher mit manchen Technologien war.
Internet war da irgendwie, naja, da lagen wir auch nicht unbedingt immer richtig,
aber einiges ließ sich schon sehr weit in die Zukunft ableiten.
Das ist jetzt hier gar nicht so einfach.
Ich würde an der Stelle noch mal einmal kurz abschließend betonen wollen,
weil wir jetzt so viel noch mal über das Wesen dieser Technologie gesprochen
haben, was kann man damit machen, was nicht.
Das Intelligente an den Dingern ist nicht, was sie am Ende machen,
sondern das Intelligente ist, dass sie lernen. Und dass sie die,
Und das wiederum heißt, dass du denen potenziell alles, was geeignet ist,
gelernt zu werden, auch beibringen kannst.
Und das könnte mir beispielsweise vorstellen, dass du vielleicht einfach so
ein Modell, wenn es dann Beethoven durchgelernt hat, einfach für besonders ausgefallene
Kreationen wieder belohnst.
Und sagst, pass auf, wir möchten bitte, dass du mehr an den Rändern noch ein
bisschen dich frei entfaltest und dass das dann auch funktionieren kann.
Es gibt glaube ich in der KI-Forschung schon immer so diesen Begriff des Embodiment,
was so ein bisschen die These ist, dass wenn du eben wirklich Intelligenz abbilden willst,
dass du dann eben auch die ganzen sinnlichen Erfahrungen mit drin haben musst
oder anders ausgedrückt, wenn du so einen Menschen haben willst,
dann brauchst du im Prinzip auch einen Roboter, der ist wie ein Mensch,
der also quasi auch das ganze Sinnliche,
wahrnimmt, Temperatur,
Umgebung, Natur, Wetter, all diese ganzen Sachen und insofern ist es auch nicht
sonderlich überraschend,
dass die Unternehmen, die jetzt so viel mit AI unterwegs sind,
auch im Bereich der Robotik fleißig versuchen sich zu engagieren,
sogar der unsägliche Musk.
Ja.
So, in all dem, diese Technologie kommt über uns in einer Welt,
in der die USA
diesen Technologiebereich dominieren und auch die Internetwirtschaft dominieren
und sich aber sehr viel Mühe geben mit Big Beautiful Bills ihre Weltdominanz
auf jeden Fall in Gefühle.
Fahrt zu bringen und wir auf eine,
aktuell drohen in eine Zukunft zu laufen, in der bestimmte Weltmächte oder Flächenmächte versuchen,
noch so die Welt zu beeinflussen.
Die USA irgendwie durch digitale, überlegene Services,
die Europa aktuell irgendwie durch Versuche, die noch irgendwie mit Gesetzen
und Regeln zu bändigen in ihrer Einflussnahme und in ihrer Macht.
Und einer dieser Versuche der Europäischen Union ist der Digital Markets Act.
Das war ja mal eine Überleitung. Super, ne? Von KI zu DMA.
Ja, ich will von ChatGPT.
Nein, aber ich sehe das wirklich in Zusammenhängen.
Das ist natürlich so ein Ding. Also DMA ist natürlich zumindest auf Papier der
Versuch hier in irgendeiner Form die Macht der Plattformen ein wenig zu bändigen.
Und das ist ja ein heeres Ziel.
Dann heißt es natürlich Choose your battles. Und, äh,
Derzeit ist natürlich wieder die Aufmerksamkeit ganz bei Apple,
weil jetzt hier irgendwie Stichtag, wir nehmen ja hier am 6.
Juli auf, morgen ist so ein bisschen der Stichtag für die EU in den aktuellen
Diskussionen mit Apple.
Die wohl eine ganze Menge Flack bekommen haben von der Europäischen Kommission
in Bezug auf die von Apple bisher umgesetzten Antworten auf diese ganzen neuen Regulierungen.
Nur nochmal so zur Erinnerung, es gibt ja diese Definition eines Gatekeepers
und die Kommission kann halt sagen, du bist jetzt ein Gatekeeper,
weil du mit deiner Plattform, mit deiner Infrastruktur, die du dir aufgebaut hast,
auf einmal den Zugang zum freien Markt einschränken kannst, wie zum Beispiel
der App Store auf dem iPhone,
was absolut nachvollziehbar ist, weil du heutzutage kein Produkt mehr auf den
Markt bringen kannst, wenn du nicht zumindest die Möglichkeit hast,
dort im App Store vertreten zu sein.
Weil die Leute installieren dann halt eine App, der schöne Spruch,
der ist ein App for that und wenn da halt keine App for that ist,
dann hast du halt potenziellen Nachteile und insofern ist es natürlich sinnvoll,
hier regulierend einzuwirken.
Die Methode der EU ist halt mehrfach schon angesprochen,
vor allem eben dieser Weg alternative App-Stores einzuklagen auf der einen Seite,
aber andererseits jetzt auch nochmal Regeln für den normalen App-Store aufzuerlegen
und darum geht es jetzt vor allem in der aktuellen Runde nochmal sehr.
Apple hat jetzt schon verschiedene Änderungen angekündigt, die sie jetzt umzusetzen
zu gedenken, jetzt in den nächsten Releases ihres Betriebssystems oder ihrer
Betriebssysteme, die davon betroffen sind.
Das sind wesentliche iOS und iPadOS.
Und das sind dann halt so Sachen wie, dass Apps jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr beschränkt
werden dürfen von Apple auf digitale Kaufangebote auf ihren eigenen Webseiten
oder in anderen Apps hinzuweisen.
Das war bisher ja extrem reglementiert.
Dann gibt es eine Umbenennung von dieser Core Technology Fee, mit der sie ja sagen,
ja okay, du kannst jetzt zwar deine App in einem anderen App Store verkaufen,
Aber du nimmst ja immer noch quasi unsere Plattform als Dienstleistung an,
für die wir ja so viel Geld bezahlen müssen.
Und da wollen wir dann diese Fee haben. Die heißt jetzt nicht mehr Fee,
die heißt jetzt Core Technology Commission.
Und es gibt noch ein paar Änderungen in Bezug auf Musikstreaming etc.
Und diese neuen Regeln sollen dann ab 1. Januar nächsten Jahres gelten.
Es ist jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen unklar, ob das jetzt so akzeptiert werden wird.
Die EU hat Apple da wohl 500 Millionen US-Dollar Strafe angedroht und auch bei
Nicht-Umsetzungen dann irgendwie noch so eine tägliche Strafe von 50 Millionen pro Tag.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Apple ein gewisses Interesse daran hat,
diese Strafen zu verhindern und das ist halt jetzt gerade Kern der Auseinandersetzung.
Da werden wir also dann wahrscheinlich ab nächster Woche mehr darüber erfahren,
wie das ausgegangen ist.
Es gibt jetzt auch einfachere Methoden, diese Marketplaces, also diese anderen
App-Stores zu installieren als bisher.
Da hat es ja Apple so richtig schön wild gemacht mit, ja hier,
dann musst du da auf die Seite und dann nochmal 50 Warnungen und dann musst
du es aus dem Web runterladen und dann kannst du es installieren und dann nochmal 30 Warnungen.
Also das ist jetzt wohl extrem gestreamlined worden von der EU oder beziehungsweise
darauf hingewirkt worden, dass Apple das mehr streamlinet, weil es dann doch
schon sehr auffällig war, wie sehr sie sich da,
mit Klauen und Kratzen irgendwie versuchen,
vor dem Einstieg von Third Party zu bewahren.
Ja und offensichtlich ist halt der DMA aber jetzt auch weiterhin der Grund,
warum Apple jetzt bestimmte Features aus ihrem Betriebssystem komplett der EU vorenthält.
Aber das ist doch auch einfach nur Strafe, oder ist das irgendeine Compliance
zu dem DMA zu erfüllen, weil das irgendwie iPhone-Mirroring,
wieso ist das jetzt auf einmal ein Problem?
Na, weil es die Regel gibt in den DMA, dass wenn du ein Gatekeeper bist,
dass du, wenn du jetzt irgendwas anbietest, ja, wie zum Beispiel so Apple Watch-Integration
von deinen eigenen Produkten, also das ist ja das Ding, meine Apple,
und deswegen ist, glaube ich, auch die Auseinandersetzung hier einfach so fierce,
Apple hat halt einfach ein etwas anderes Modell als die meisten anderen Anbieter, ja.
Die setzen halt auf eine vertikale Integration ihrer Produkte und sagen halt,
ja, aber weil das so ist, ist es ja so sicher und so einfach zu benutzen und da ist auch was dran.
Ja, das kann man jetzt so oder so sehen, aber so ganz ohne Punkt sind sie da auf gar keinen Fall.
Und sagen halt, naja, das ist halt unser Weg, wie wir das machen,
ihr könnt das ja genauso machen, nur weil wir jetzt so erfolgreich sind, uns dann zu zwingen,
dass wir automatisch jedes Feature, was wir für uns entwickeln und was sozusagen,
die Einfachheit der Benutzung ausmacht, was weiß ich, du machst deine AirPods
auf und musst die halt nicht so dusselig wie andere Bluetooth-Geräte mit irgendwelchen PIN-Codes,
pairn, sondern die haben halt einfach einen eigenen Pairing-Prozess und dann
geht da ein schönes Fensterchen auf und dann hast du noch eine Grafik,
wo das Produkt schön 360 Grad rum rotiert.
Sehr angenehm.
Ja, sehr angenehm. Drückst du halt auf einen Button und dann sagt die Kommission,
ja, aber das kann ja nicht sein, dass ihr sowas Schönes für euch baut und alle
anderen dürfen das dann auch nicht haben.
Warum haben die anderen denn das auf ihren Plattformen nicht auch schon so hübsch gebaut?
Die Frage ist doch, warum haben die anderen das auf ihren Plattformen,
sondern bei den Kopfhörern wäre das Beispiel ja jetzt,
dass jeder Kopfhörer in irgendeiner Weise dieses Spiel mitspielen können müsste.
Jetzt ist die Frage, und langfristig denke ich mal, kann man das auch argumentieren,
dass so ein Vorteil, den man hat, vielleicht langfristig auch in irgendeiner
Form mitigiert werden muss.
Aber so wie die Regelung derzeit ist, ist es sozusagen von Tag eins an muss es so sein.
Mit anderen Worten, was Apple jetzt hier befürchtet, offensichtlich,
ist, dass wenn sie jetzt, also es geht um, jetzt konkret, das ist ja gerade
genannt, dieses iPhone-Mirroring ist die Funktion, dass du dein iPhone quasi
von dem Macintosh aus steuern kannst.
Sprich, du verbindest dich dahin, dann wird das Telefon, wird der Bildschirm
schwarz, so kannst du da nichts mehr dran machen,
sondern das User-Interface marschiert in ein Fenster auf dem Mac und du kannst
dann da mit Track und Drop machen und Dateien reinziehen und über das Ding benutzen mit der Maus.
Schönes Feature, ich habe das mal ausprobiert, total geil, will ich haben.
So, ihre Befürchtung offenbar ist jetzt die, dass wenn sie das jetzt machen
und Apple, Entschuldigung, die EU beschließt,
ja, macOS ist jetzt aber auch ein Gatekeeper, dass sie das dann eben auch automatisch
und zwar immer von Tag 1 an, ab dem das Feature existiert und nicht irgendwann mal,
sozusagen immer auch gleich mit einer Third-Party-API ausrüsten müssen.
Was natürlich ein ganz anderer Aufwand ist, als wenn du das einfach nur mit
deinen eigenen Sachen machst, intern und so. Sowas muss sich ja auch erstmal entwickeln.
Oft ist der erste Ansatz, ja, funktioniert zwar irgendwie, aber läuft dann gegen
eine Wand, dann musst du das nochmal reimplementieren.
Und wenn man das dann halt auch noch für Third Party macht, kommen nochmal ganz
andere Authentifizierungs- und Security-Fragen mit dazu, die du eben so einfach
nicht hast, wenn das alles closed shop ist.
Und das ist so ein bisschen der Reibepunkt, glaube ich, an der Stelle,
der auch nachvollziehbar ist.
Und ich finde, die DMA geht an der Stelle zu weit.
Ich finde das ja okay, dass man sagt, okay, so etwas wie Bluetooth-Kopfhörerkopplung
ist jetzt hier bei euch ganz toll und die anderen kriegen das so hübsch nicht hin.
Wir wollen das jetzt auch alle so hübsch haben. Dann kann man ja sagen, okay, in drei Jahren.
Ja, müsste ja dann auch soweit sein, das auch für die anderen anzubieten oder so.
Das wäre ja schon mal ein ganz anderer Ansatz, aber dieser Ansatz, den gibt es so nicht.
Und auch generell die Frage, wann zwingt dich, sagen wir mal,
dein eigenes Prinzip einer vertikalen Integration deiner Produkte,
was ist eigentlich genau die Motivation oder was ist die Argumentation,
dass man das tun muss.
Weil das ist ja sozusagen, das ist ja der Vorteil, die investieren ja,
dass es bei ihnen halt toller ist als bei anderen, aber dann quasi per Gesetz,
gezwungen zu sein, jeden Vorteil, den man sich erarbeitet mit der eigenen Kreativität
und interessanten Lösungen, den dann auch automatisch allen anderen,
die da nichts tun, zur Verfügung zu stellen, verstehe ich irgendwie so ein bisschen die,
Logik nicht.
Vor allem, was soll das besser machen?
Ja, ich bin es ein bisschen leid, weil alle dann gleich wieder auf mich einhauen
und ich bin ja so der totale Apple-Apologet und so weiter, aber man muss auch
einfach mal sehen, dass es einfach auch verschiedene Modelle geben kann,
die einfach miteinander konkurrieren können,
ohne dass es dann gleich wieder so eingestampft werden muss,
weil es wird einfach nur dazu führen, dass wir weniger Innovationen haben statt mehr.
Tim will iPhone-Mirroring haben, ich fand das Beispiel mit dem App Store aber
schon sehr viel sehr viel eindrücklicher. Und da haben wir ja eigentlich drüber gesprochen.
Und da ist, glaube ich, habe ich auch gerade rausgehört, dass du das auch so siehst.
Dass ich was genau hier so sehe.
Dass das eine,
marktbeherrschende Stellung ist.
Ja, ganz klar. Und eine Gatekeeper-Position. Genau. Und ich bin auch voll für
Regulierung. Habe ich auch schon immer gemeint.
Aber dann sollte die richtig treffen.
Ja, die Frage ist, was reguliert man? Und ich denke, nee, jetzt brauchen wir
noch mehrere von diesen App-Stores ist Quatsch.
Du musst den App-Store selber regulieren. Und so eine Regelung wie ihr dürft
nicht Apps verbieten, einfach irgendwo ins Web zu linken.
Das ist völlig okay.
Also das muss so sein. Also diese ganzen Auflagen, die müssen definitiv reduziert werden.
Und man kann auch über Payment und diese ganzen Regelungen und vor allem über
das Zulassen von Apps reden.
Weil das ist ja sozusagen das, was hinter dieser Idee mit, ja wenn es die anderen
App-Stores gibt, dann gibt es auch mal Apps, die es bei euch nicht gibt.
Damit es jetzt auch irgendwie Porno-Apps gibt und das ist halt irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, welche Retro-Emulatoren gibt.
So viel gibt es da auch noch nicht. Und ich glaube auch nicht,
dass es da so sehr viel geben wird, um ehrlich zu sein.
Aber man könnte natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch einfach sagen,
es muss mal klare juristische Regeln und Verpflichtungen geben,
auch für den Anbieter der Plattform,
unter welchen Bedingungen eine App überhaupt abgelehnt werden darf.
Und davon sehe ich halt derzeit gar nichts. Und das wäre gerade für kleine Entwickler
ja viel besser, wenn du einen Klageweg
hast, wenn es so eine Diskriminierungsverhinderung gibt, dass du weißt,
wenn ich da jetzt diesen juristischen Prozess einschreite, dann darf das für
mich keine negativen Konsequenzen haben.
Ich darf dann nicht gesperrt werden, deswegen etc.
Weil das sind die eigentlichen Probleme, die die Developer haben.
Das sind die Sachen, weswegen die sich gegen bestimmte Dinge nicht wehren.
Wenn Apple sagt, nehmen wir nicht auf, was willst du dann machen?
Willst du dann Rechtsanwälte beauftragen und gegen Apple klagen?
Das kannst du halt total vergessen als One-Man-Show oder auch nur mit kleineren
Unternehmen mit vielleicht 10, 20 Leuten.
Das machst du halt einfach nicht. Und da wäre es meiner Meinung nach sinnvoller,
mal klare Rechtsgrundlagen, Ansprüche zu definieren, sodass eben auch Apple
in der Pflicht ist, dass wenn sie eine Ablehnung machen, die dann auch formal
zu belegen und offen zu legen.
Und derzeit sagen die einfach so, nö, ja hier Paragraf 15 hast du verletzt.
Und das müsste an der Stelle einfach verpflichtender sein.
Ich glaube, dass man darüber sehr viel mehr erreichen kann, wenn es gut formuliert ist,
als jetzt so mit dieser Methode, die für mich so ein bisschen so ein Einprügeln
ist, ohne dass jetzt wirklich für Anwender oder Entwickler rauskommt.
In den Aushandlungen des DMA oder der Anwendung des DMA,
hat sich jetzt die Europäische Union entschieden, dass es da demnächst ein Mitspracherecht
geben wird über die Anwendung, wie der DMA ausgelegt wird.
Und zwar für diese betroffenen Konzerne selber.
Also das Handelsblatt interpretiert das als ein Einknicken, dass die Kommission jetzt quasi sagt, okay,
wir schwächen dann den DMA ab und beugen uns letztendlich dem verschärften Handelskrieg,
den Donald Trump ja angezettelt hat.
Also Zitat des Handelsblattartikets, ein solcher Schritt würde eine deutliche
Abschwächung der Regulierung der Tech-Konzerne aus den USA bedeuten.
Kritiker befürchten sogar, dass damit faktisch das Ende der Regulierung eingeläutet
würde, was wiederum die deutlich kleinere EU-Digitalwirtschaft im Keim ersticken könnte.
Ich glaube, das Risiko steht hier auf jeden Fall im Raum.
Wenn man sich anhört, dass du, glaube ich, schon einen inhaltlichen Punkt hast,
dass häufig diese Regulierung vielleicht auch wirklich nicht unbedingt so zielgerichtet ist,
Und könnte man vielleicht hoffen, dass es etwas bringt, wenn die da nochmal
mit jemandem reden, der sich auskennt.
Aber natürlich wird die US-Position immer dagegen sein.
Also es ist ja völlig klar, dass die diese Regulierungen nicht wollen und sich
bemühen werden, die zu verhindern.
Interessant.
Jetzt vor allem halt auf internationaler Ebene, was ja quasi neu ist.
Okay, also Digital Markets Act als, ja, tatsächlich Hoheitswettkampf.
Also die USA bauen diese Technologien. Die haben diese Geräte,
die definieren, wie die sind.
Und das ist damit eine Macht, die sie über den gesamten Planeten haben oder
die Apple über den gesamten Planeten hat.
Und diese Macht ist natürlich auch im Interesse der USA.
Und wenn in der EU Staaten sich zusammenschließen und sagen,
wir schreiben jetzt Gesetze dagegen und hegen das ein,
dann ist das ein globaler Kampf um Einfluss, um Macht, um Einschränkungen von Macht,
die man hier dahinter sieht.
Und natürlich auch um wirtschaftliche Nutzung dieser Macht.
Wir hatten eine Innenministerkonferenz.
Wie schön.
Ja, und die Innenministerkonferenz hat, die schreiben dann so Beschlüsse.
Und die haben jetzt einen Beschluss formuliert, ich zitiere da mal ein bisschen raus.
Die IMK ist bestürzt über die schreckliche Messertat am Hamburger Hauptbahnhof vom 23.05.,
bei der 18 Menschen durch eine psychisch kranke Täterin zum Teil schwer verletzt
worden sind und drückt den Betroffenen und den Angehörigen ihr besonderes Mitgefühl aus. Schau mal.
Schon mal faszinierend, dass es dann so eine Innenministerkonferenz gibt,
die dann erstmal ihre Protokolle dazu nutzt, irgendwelche Mitgefühlsbekundungen zu formulieren.
Da weißt du schon, jetzt geht es ans Eingemachte.
Und jetzt kommt, es wird nicht lange dauern und dann finden sich so,
wir möchten natürlich alles tun, um das Risiko solcher Taten zu reduzieren. Ja klar, klar, klar.
Die Innenministerkonferenz hält es für erforderlich, ein zuverlässigeres und
wirksameres System zur Früherkennung und Minimierung von Risiken bei Menschen
mit psychischer Erkrankung zu etablieren. Ja, okay. Okay.
Relevante Erkenntnisse zu psychischen Erkrankungen müssen den zuständigen Behörden,
gegebenenfalls auch der Polizei, zugänglich und ein Datenaustausch möglich gemacht werden.
Außerdem Etablierung geeigneter länderübergreifender Verfahren,
um die in den Ländern vorliegenden Informationen zusammenzuführen.
Eine verlässliche Grundlage zur Risikobewertung und effektive Handlungsempfehlungen zu erhalten.
Das heißt, sie wollen eine zentrale, ein Bundesdatensatz der psychisch Kranken.
Um Oder ein Datenaustausch.
Naja, also ein Datenaustausch ist das Zusammenführen. Es ist ja nicht hier,
komm wir tauschen, ich gebe dir meine, du gibst mir deine und dann haben wir.
Also das ist ja, also die wollen ein Zentralregister für psychisch kranke Menschen.
Weiterhin sind dann auch, also da sind auch Überlegungen drin,
wie, ob man denn Medikamentennahme erzwingen kann, dass man das quasi rechtlich,
dazu zwingt, bestimmte Medikamente zu nehmen.
Das ist, sagen wir mal, so ein klassischer Fall von, da schießen,
glaube ich, gerade die Leute ein bisschen weit über das Ziel hinaus.
Da gibt es eine ganze Menge Verbände. Natürlich die Deutsche Psychotherapeutische
Vereinigung sieht das natürlich als ein riesiges Problem.
Die vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen greifen in Grundrechte ein, verengen die Sicht
auf psychische Erkrankungen, gefährden zentrale Elemente psychotherapeutischer
Versorgung. Ja klar, ich meine, wenn ich da in irgendeinem Register lande,
gehe ich da sicherlich nicht hin.
Die psychotherapeutische Schweigepflicht ist natürlich rechtlich geschützt und
wenn man jetzt sagt, ja pass auf, aber du musst bestimmte Diagnosen irgendwie den Bullen melden,
dann steigt natürlich die Schwelle, sich überhaupt Hilfe zu suchen und damit
wird natürlich am Ende Prävention und Stabilisierung weiter gefährdet als optimiert.
Und gleichzeitig weisen sie darauf hin, dass es massive Versorgungslücken gibt
in der psychotherapeutischen Versorgung, aber auch in der Unterbringung behandlungslüftiger Menschen.
Und ja, ich denke, das ist wirklich...
Ernsthaft? Ich meine, was denken diese Leute?
Was denken diese Innenminister? Die müssen einfach, also.
Es muss doch jemand was tun.
Es muss jemand was tun.
Die Leute sind doch beunruhig, die haben Angst. Da muss auch irgendwas getan werden.
Und das ist halt, sagen wir mal, der typische pavlosche Reflex,
glaube ich, von so Innenministern, die dann immer irgendwas fordern müssen, auch wenn das,
nichts ist, worüber man mal vorher drüber nachgedacht hat. Sondern man haut mal einen raus.
Ja, also das ist schon naja, also dieses Register für psychisch Kranke ist ja
schon eine etwas ältere Idee.
Das haben die jetzt nicht spontan ausgerechnet.
Wie alt ist das? Würdest du sagen? Also ich habe das noch nicht gehört.
Doch, haben wir sogar hier in der Sendung schon drüber gesprochen.
Ach, sag doch sowas nicht. Das ist ja beschämend.
Psychisch Kranke,
war so,
Anfang 25 gab es da so die ersten Dinge zu und ich glaube, wir haben auch darüber
gesprochen, dass das im Koalitionsvertrag erwähnt wird.
Psychisch. Kann ich mal eben gucken, was der, ob das im Koalitionsvertrag,
nee, steht nicht im Koalitionsvertrag.
Nicht explizit geplante Regelung, um Risikopotenziale bei Menschen mit psychischen
Auffälligkeiten zu erfassen. Ich meine, das ist einfach nur ein anderer Begriff.
Sehr schön. Chat-Kontrolle, gibt es auch was Neues?
Oh, was?
Sehr schön. Die Idee der Chat-Kontrolle, drei Jahre wird die diskutiert.
Sie hat sechs Ratspräsidentschaften und insgesamt 35 Sitzungen hinter sich.
Die EU-Staaten schaffen es aber nicht, sich auf eine gemeinsame Position zu einigen.
Polen, die ja die Ratspräsidentschaft zuletzt hatten, Die hatten unter anderem,
die jetzige Regierung hatte einen staatstrojanischen Skandal der PiS-Partei gegen sich.
Die wissen also, wie sich das anfühlt, wenn die Handys abgehört werden und waren
vehement quasi gegen eine radikale Auslegung der Chatkontrolle.
Dänemark hat jetzt übernommen, die finden verpflichtende Chat-Kontrolle gut.
Und es gibt einen dänischen Entwurf, der irgendwie bei Netzpolitik.org veröffentlicht wurde.
Am Ende werden sie diskutieren über verpflichtete Scannen.
Auf den Geräten.
Und natürlich von Inhalten, die vor der Kommunikation und nach der Kommunikation,
also tatsächlich auch von Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten Inhalten.
Das ist das, was hier diskutiert wird.
KI-Überwachung aller deiner Kommunikationsinhalte auf deinem Gerät mit einer
Direktleitung an der Meldestelle, die an die Polizei angeschlossen ist.
Es ist wirklich absurd, aber in diese Richtung wird Dänemark jetzt wieder lenken.
Und die deutsche Innenministerkonferenz sagt, sie hätten natürlich gerne so
eine Chatkontrolle, sie hätten auch gerne Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Wir hatten auch schon darüber gesprochen, löschen wollen sie nicht,
das ist ihnen dann doch zu anstrengend.
Und von Dobrindt brauchst du eigentlich nichts zu erwarten. Das heißt,
die deutsche Position ist noch nicht irgendwie explizit, aber wir hatten uns
ja als CCC schon an Dobrindt gewendet, um da mal auf das Problem hinzuweisen.
Genau, dann gab es eine öffentliche Konsultation der Kommission zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Da haben sie 5000 Stellungnahmen aus ganz Europa bekommen, die sie jetzt auswerten müssen.
Bin auch mal gespannt, wie viel Überwachung ist denn wohl okay.
Da haben sie jetzt Antworten bekommen. Müssen sie mal jetzt lesen.
Ach, Lesen, ich bitte dich, das schmeißt mal einfach in die AI rein.
Ja, und dann lässt sich von der AI sagen.
Was Sache ist, ja. Die brauchen auch Therapie.
Und zuletzt hatten wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon natürlich über viele
Möglichkeiten der KI-Nutzung gesprochen.
Unter anderem auch darüber, dass diese Technologie sich natürlich für das Strukturieren
großer Datenmengen und Durchsuchen großer Datenmengen eignet und dass eines
der Produkte, die da an Staaten verkauft werden,
dass die Software Palantir ist, die von dem Unternehmen abläuft.
Vertrieben wird, dass Peter Thiel zu diesem Zweck gegründet hat.
Er hat ein AI-Überwachungs-Software-Unternehmen, Dienstleister geschaffen.
Und ich meine, während Peter Thiel, es ist ja so absurd, wenn das jemand im
Roman geschrieben hätte, würde es ihn ja auslachen. Aber ich meine, dieser Mann hat J.D.
Vance neben Donald Trump etabliert.
Der hat wirklich enorm krude Ansichten.
Er sagt sehr klar, dass er glaubt, dass Demokratie und Freiheit sich nicht verbinden
lassen, weil er sich eben von der Demokratie eingeschränkt fühlt.
Es gibt ja in letzter Zeit mehr Podcasts und Dokumentationen,
die sich mit dem auseinandersetzen.
Der Ross Douthat hat ein ungefähr einstündiges Gespräch mit dem Peter Thiel
gehört, wo man sich mal so seine Ansichten anhören kann.
Ihm findet einfach zu wenig Fortschritt und Innovation statt das ist eines seiner größten Probleme.
Er
würde sich wünschen, dass Donald Trump irgendwie noch krasser vorgeht und am
Ende spricht er noch ein bisschen über den Antichristen das ist irgendwas, das ist so sein,
also der hat irgendwie so eine Antichrist Macke und der spricht immer vom Antichristen und,
das wird wirklich zunehmend,
fragt man sich ernsthaft also ich glaube der hat halt nicht so ein Drogenproblem wie der Elon Musk,
Sondern ganz im Gegenteil, ist er relativ scharp im Kopf.
Trotzdem, sag ich mal, gelingt es ihm eigentlich nicht, da so den Eindruck zu
vermitteln, dass er irgendwie noch so seelisch noch ganz auf dem Level ist.
Ja, das sind Leute, die die Welt ganz anders wahrnehmen als wir.
Die definieren das nicht so über Demokratie und dass alles gut für alle ist,
sondern geht es dann im Wesentlichen um Einflusssphären und sozusagen die wirklichen
Entscheider und der Rest ist alles nur so Fußvolk im Spiel, in dem Sinne gar keine Regel.
Dieser ganze libertäre Wahnsinn, den das Silicon Valley ergriffen hat.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht schön. Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus
wollte, ist, in Baden-Württemberg wird dann gerade diskutiert,
denn die Baden-Württemberger Polizei möchte das natürlich auch haben.
Also, ich meine, es ist eine Sache zu sagen, okay, komm, wir möchten einen,
KI-unterstützten Polizeiüberwachungsstaat bauen. Das ist so ein Level. Aber das ist Level 1.
Level 2 ist, wir kaufen die Scheiße von Peter Thiel. Das ist einfach ein Level mehr.
Und das.
Du willst das nicht. Fassen wir es mal so zusammen. Du findest es nicht gut.
Laut Baden-Württembergischen Innenministerium hat die Polizei bereits einen
Vertrag mit Palantir abgeschlossen.
Und jetzt musst du ...
Wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass wir dann feststellen,
dass in Deutschland diese Software dann eben außerhalb ihrer,
ursprünglichen Versprechungen genutzt wird. In Hessen 15.000 Mal im Jahr und
wir rütteln da gerade an eiligen Grundfesten unserer Grundrechte.
Ja, ich will nicht sagen, dass
es jetzt unbedingt völlig schlecht ist oder grundsätzlich abzulehnen ist,
dass Polizeien Daten, auf die sie Zugriff haben, auch irgendwie besser verarbeiten können.
Ja, aber dann bitte mit dem Ziel,
nur das zu tun und nicht irgendwie von irgendeinem Trump-supportenden Milliardär
aus den USA, der irgendwie sich mit der, der ernsthaft im Interview mit der
New York Times vom Antichristen redet.
Also das ist doch, also hier wird die ganze Zeit eine von Souveränität und sonst
was erzählt und Apple darf kein iPhone-Mirroring machen, aber die Bullen kaufen
bei Peter Thiel oder was.
Also da geht doch irgendwas, da gibt es doch Optimierungsbedarf, möchte ich sagen.
Hatten wir jetzt nicht ein Digitalministerium? Wir haben ein Digitalministerium.
Ich habe übrigens auch den Digitalminister getroffen, letzte Woche,
kurz gemeinsam bei einer Konferenz.
Er hat nur gesagt, was er jetzt alles vorhat. Bisher hat er,
glaube ich, noch nicht wirklich was gemacht.
Das ist auch alles, was ich bisher wahrgenommen habe.
Ja, ist halt nicht Donald Trump, der sofort hingeht und die Staatsform ändert
in den ersten 100 Tagen von Demokratie auf Demokratur.
Ich meine,
ist doch auch gut, wenn er jetzt nicht rumläuft und sagt, er will eine Mauer bauen.
Schau mal, schau mal.
Noch hat er ja Welpenschutz.
Absolut und er hat ja auch eine sehr große Aufgabe vor sich,
überhaupt diese Infrastruktur für dieses Ministerium zu bauen und ich glaube,
als jemand aus der Wirtschaft, der jetzt da mit den ganzen,
mit diesen ganzen Behörden zu tun hat, kann man ihm nur wünschen, dass er,
gutes Nervenkostüm hat.
Hattest du den Eindruck, dass er ausreichend belastbar ist und kann in ganzen Sätzen reden?
In meiner Wahrnehmung hat er ganze Sätze formuliert.
Das ist doch schon mal am Anfang.
Wie du schon sagst, der muss jetzt erst mal dieses Ministerium bauen.
Das wäre natürlich jetzt was anderes anderes, wenn es das Ministerium schon
gäbe und es jetzt schon wirklich auch seine politische Wirkung entfalten könnte.
Aber das ist ja jetzt gerade noch nicht der Moment.
Wir werden auch die KI nicht von der Polizei fernhalten können.
Die Frage ist ja nicht das Ob, sondern eher das Wie.
Und dieses Wie, man macht da so direkte Kanäle in die USA in zweifelhafte Unternehmen
auf, das ist keine gute Idee für so eine hoheitliche Aufgabe.
So, Schluss jetzt. Genug KI.
Ja.
Zwei Stunden haben wir jetzt auch gleich voll.
Ja, dann sind wir jetzt fertig.
Drei Viertel davon Feedback. Fand ich aber mal wirklich einen lohnenswerten Ausflug.
Ich glaube, die Diskussion ist auch noch lange nicht abgeschlossen,
wie sollte sie es auch sein.
Aber auf jeden Fall schön. Wir müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen gucken mit dem
Sommer, wie wir da jetzt in die Termine kommen. aber es wird ein bisschen knifflig.
Von daher haben wir die Sendung jetzt auch schon lang gemacht,
dass ihr sie auch zweimal oder dreimal hören könnt.
Vielleicht nochmal abschließend, bei diesem ganzen Thema KI,
man merkt, dass das ja auch,
also erstens sehr erfreulich und auch sehr positiv, dass die meisten Kommentare
ja einfach auch wirklich inhaltlich und an der Technologie nachdenkend sind.
Am Thema selber, nicht spezifisch auf die Kommentare zur Sendung bezogen,
sondern so grundsätzlich, wenn man sich mal so anguckt, wie wird über dieses
Thema geredet, in sozialen Medien, in der echten Welt, merkt man, dass das,
sehr emotional aufgeladen ist, dieses Thema.
Also, und das kann ich erstmal damit erklären, dass die Menschen,
oder ich würde es mir auch damit erklären, also ich fühle mich auch davon,
irgendwie von dieser Ungewissheit, die mit dieser Technologie kommt,
in irgendeiner Weise unwohl oder bedroht, weil ich nicht weiß, ob alles,
oder weil ich nicht weiß, wie viel Schlechtes von dem, was damit entstehen wird,
mich trifft und wie viel Gutes mich trifft.
Aber ich denke, der wichtige Weg, damit umzugehen, ist auf jeden Fall diese
Technologie so gut wie möglich zu verstehen und so gut wie möglich zu ergründen,
damit man sie hoffentlich gut einschätzen kann und mit ihr in der Welt umgehen kann.
Und eine Technologie, die nur wenige verstehen, in den Händen von nur einigen
wenigen, ist echt ein Problem.
Und deswegen kann ich wirklich nur alle ermutigen, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen,
wie das funktioniert, was man damit machen kann, was nicht,
wie sich das potenziell weiterentwickeln wird, welche Möglichkeiten man in der
eigenen privaten wirtschaftlichen Tätigkeit hat und so weiter.
Das ist bei jeder Technologie so,
die eine derartige gesellschaftliche Bedeutung haben wird,
dass man möglichst aufpassen sollte, dass man sich derer ermächtigt und dafür
sorgt, dass diese Technologie irgendwie in unseren Händen bleibt.
Ja. So machen wir Ende hier mit dieser Sendung. So geht es raus. Leute.
Super.
Und dann hören wir uns die Tage wieder. Gucken wir mal wieder zusammenkommen.
Genau.
Bis bald.
Bis denn. Ciao, ciao.